me kevin smith have you been looking for
all my old podcasts the ones i started
recording back in 2007 well guess what i
found them they're all hiding
in that kevin smith club all that shit's
not exclusive enough we got three more
shows that are only going to be going on
at that kevin smith club the return
of plus one the marital podcast that i
did with jennifer for years
wake and bake with kev that's right a
video show where every morning whatever
i'm doing while i'm smoking man you're
gonna hang out with me and then of
course
the exclusive kebcast man that's the
podcast of me just by myself
or i just kind of do my own self therapy
while you listen
see all the video you've never seen
including exclusive movies and
live shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making pins
and miniature versions of my old scripts
if you want to be involved in the least
exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club
now's your chance to club kevin smith
hey oh that hurt uh hey man right there
i'll tell you in a second uh welcome to
fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm mark
hey um all right kids uh full disclosure
i had oral surgery on friday went to the
periodontist
and uh they put me out it was so intense
that
like they told me like you're gonna have
an anesthesiologist
so wonderful doctor she put me out i've
never been like put under
you know in my life like uh i think i've
during the heart attack they kept me in
a state of twilight
but i never went under like completely
out so that was the thing i was most
terrified about
where they're like you know they're
gonna put the needle in you and then
[ __ ] you fall asleep that sounds like
execution to me
and i kept telling her i was just like
you got to bring me out of this she's
like that's my whole job and i'm like i
know but like
for real you got to bring me out of this
cause like if i
die in a periodontal chair
all they'll say on the internet is his
filthy mouth killed him
yeah dirty mouth he's like you've got to
bring it
back and she was like are you really
that famous and i was like lady
when i was coming into the building
paparazzi would take a picture of me and
stuff
thank god they got me before i went in
because after
i was just a [ __ ] bloody mess doctor
my doctor zeb did a
wonderful job he's fantastic felt no
pain
still feel no pain however
what i do feel and you may hear it as i
speak
is um in order to do what they did
they had to go deep into my gums
and scrape the roots of all my teeth and
then they pulled
three teeth um
there are stitches in my gums
literally between every one of my teeth
right now
so it's not painful but i'm acutely
aware of it
it's almost like having [ __ ] stuck in
your teeth and you just want to like
pull it out but if you do
your gums will open and you'll [ __ ]
bleed out so
i didn't know if we were going to be
able to do the show this weekend that's
why we moved it from saturday to sunday
because i was like i i don't know what
kind of [ __ ] condition i'm going to
be and i might be like
oddly enough no pain i mean the guy's
great at what he does
they didn't give me any like painkillers
that's worth no noteworthy they gave me
like
tylenol with codeine and my wife was
like that's it you got rough
but i you know i'm not i don't like
using pain meds but
in order to go through the procedure
i had to cut off the smoking
so i am four days without smoking weed
and let me tell you something
i don't know how you [ __ ] do it
why would anyone choose to live like
this this is unbelievable like
life is so gray that's very dean martin
of you
who once said i feel sorry for people
who don't drink because when they wake
up in the morning that's as good as
they're gonna feel all day
kinda i mean i'm with him i you know
i ooze is a whole different beast but
i could kind of i can kind of understand
what he's saying
um yeah it's weird man i'm not like
what i'm really happy about though is
anyone who was ever like you're a
[ __ ] weed addict i'm like number one
you cannot get physically addicted to
weed
um and they're like yeah but you never
stop smoking weed i was like well
there's no never really a good reason
i was presented with a good reason and
i've now stopped and i'm not
fiending like i'm not like you know
shitty with everyone or throwing things
or like i want
[ __ ] weed or anything like that so
it's nice to know that i have discipline
over the body still that like you know
it is a choice
when i [ __ ] spark up it's not like i
gotta get that [ __ ] thc of me
apparently i can [ __ ] literally live
without it but
i ask you again why why
spoilers life without weed here's the
difference right
life with weed you look like the vision
from wanda vision life without weed you
look like the white vision we saw in the
[ __ ] credits sequence
it's a vision just colorless devoid of
[ __ ] life
so i miss it but i'm not like like
you know it's just i i'm befuddled as to
why
anybody would want to live without
smoking weed
did you know that um
we don't know how anesthesia does what
it does
we know why it doesn't like we we know
that if you add this much
to the body it will knock you out but
they don't know precisely what's going
on
it's
how do you know how to do this we just
do why does it do what it does
we don't know if you told me this last
week i would cancel that appointment i'm
like you guys don't know enough about
this [ __ ] mark bernardin tells me that
human beings don't know enough about
anesthesia like who i'm like mark click
yeah it's like trial and error they
figured out how to not kill people but
still
shut them down but they're not entirely
sure why it does what it does to the
brain
it's fascinating like you know my my
wife she's had it before so she told me
she's like you won't even
they're gonna count you down and then
you won't even feel it you'll be out and
stuff
and i didn't she didn't count me down
like at one point when everything was
set up
she was like because she brings her kit
to the doctor's office this tower and
[ __ ] puts the needle i think she put the
needle here
and um you know she's like i put oxygen
in your nose
and then at one point she was like all
right we're off and i was like you
started it already
she's like yeah but it's not gonna hit
you hard right away it comes in waves
and i was like what do you mean oh and
then you hi
instantly there was this like hey man
this is pretty [ __ ] goofy and then
the next thing i remember because i told
her i was like
i feel a little high she's like yeah
it's kicking him the next thing i
remember is her going
mr smith and opening my eyes and i it
was [ __ ] over
and that was five hours five
hours can i did i tell you
i don't know if i talked about it last
week i don't think i did
so because i think this happened during
the week i talked to the doctor
ahead of time you know because he heard
i was nervous and he gave me a shout and
he was like how are you feeling i said
terrified
and he goes why are you scared i said
what if i don't come out of the
anesthesia he goes that's the least of
your worries
that'll be fine your doctor's great
you'll that i wouldn't worry about that
whatsoever and so
uh i said well you know i don't know
oral pain i'm a real chicken
like that's why i haven't gone to get
cleanings as
as i should and have wound up in this
[ __ ] position kinda it's also genetic
um but i was like uh you know i i
like i i i just uh i mean i'm scared of
mouth pain he's like we're gonna go out
of our way and make sure you don't have
mouth pain but you will there's gonna
you'll be aware of it and to be fair
i have no pain like i am aware of it but
there's no pain but he said to me he
goes um
you know uh you can't drink anything
before the procedure for like you know
from what time is our procedure is it 12
30
so four in the morning on you can't
drink anything and i said what happens
if i do he goes this bad if you have a
half a glass of water i have to call off
the operation
so a whole time you know before i went
there i was like all i have to do is
drink one glass of water this shit's
over
but um he said also
you know i said why is will i expect to
rate water choke on my own
[ __ ] vomit or something he goes no
but like you're gonna be in the chair
for five hours
and you're going to be sedated you're
gonna be out cold
it's okay and he goes well before we
start
we're gonna make sure we take you to the
bathroom so you have to go to the
bathroom or anything i said oh
i'm worried about that [ __ ] i said i'm
like a camel i could hold it for [ __ ]
days man i ain't jason muse
like [ __ ] he's got the bladder of an
infant i'm i can [ __ ] hold it
and he goes okay but there are options
and i was like what do you mean options
and he's like well we have things here
for you that
you could wear that like you know look
we all wind up wearing them eventually
and i was like are you offering me a
diaper doctor and he was like yeah he
put on a diaper so that way you know
you go to the bathroom so i said i
already feel
ancient by virtue of the fact that i'm
going to a periodontist and doing this
[ __ ]
if i put on an adult diaper i'm done
like i might as well just [ __ ] what
if i fall in love with it and i'm like
why haven't i been wearing this my whole
life
you just let it go and [ __ ] i was like
no i'll pinch it my shit's still good
so i went through the whole operation
and
afterwards when they woke me up when
they were mr smith and you know they
were
you know i was like what the [ __ ] when
are you starting there like you're done
first thing i did was put my hand in my
crotch to make sure that i had [ __ ]
pissed myself
proud to say mark that i did not
you [ __ ] yourself but yeah that part i
want to talk about
[ __ ] crap my pants because i was so
scared um it was it was weird man i
you know but it's over i go back to see
him on monday
and he checks my stitches and [ __ ] and
so you know he told me he's like look
you know we're gonna get to know each
other real well and i'm
he goes i'm 49 you're 50 we're going to
know each other until one of us dies
he's going because we're just going to
keep working on your mouth he's going
you know
but when i'm all done with you 10 years
from now or more
he goes you will have a third set of
teeth and i was like i thought we only
get two set of teeth he goes well as
you know body does that he's going but
science now we can give you
your third set of teeth i was like what
do you mean he's like implants screw
ends and [ __ ] and i was like
that's like all of them and he goes well
you could do dentures i was like my
parents had dentures since i was a kid
always sitting right on the sink in a
[ __ ] thing
and he goes you shouldn't he goes it's
the 21st century
with with the means that you have at
your disposal
there's no reason that you should be
wearing denture plates do you understand
me and i was like but i mean that's how
i was raised he was going
science of the mouth leaps forward every
year he's going if you've gotten
implants three years ago
they're archaic compared to what we
could do now he's going so by the time
we start doing implants on you
we're talking quasi-futuristic [ __ ] and
stuff and he's going human beings
weren't meant to live past 50.
so we've been trying to figure out how
to save our teeth for longer than that
he's going so
implants is like the your future it's
the way to go
like a shark's teeth you get like two
and three rows of those [ __ ]
just hell yes that'd be amazing man but
apparently
you know like a few years ago one of my
dentists was like hey man
you got a a bridge i'd gotten a bridge
when i was in new york shooting cop out
one of the other you know [ __ ]
bruce willis was one toothache and then
i actually had another two thing
and so the dentist there this lady gave
me like a bridge took out the one tooth
and put a bridge between the two
and my dentist out here who is like uh
john mirage he's like
dentist to the start he does ben he does
matt he does think
anyone [ __ ] famous he does their
teeth and [ __ ] so
he you know he's a real perfectionist as
an artist and he's like i can't stand
that bridge they gave you i really want
to get it the [ __ ] out of there and i
was like well what would you do
to do a new bridge he's like no i'd do
an implant tooth i was like what's that
he's like we drill into your skull and
put it
i said i'm not [ __ ] doing that [ __ ]
that's that's all i'm going to be doing
apparently for the next 10 years
according to my periodontist he's like
yeah he's like if you want teeth that's
what you will be doing
so uh you know for everyone that ever
said he's got a [ __ ] filthy mouth
they have no idea how right they were
mark
and in the next 10 years it'll be
[ __ ] spotless oh the next section
my [ __ ] teeth are going to outlive me
um i have in this bag my
molars i won't show them to the crowd
because they'll it'll make people wretch
but they they let me walk with them and
i keep them on my desk as a [ __ ]
reminder to
keep a clean mouth i inspect them on a
necklace at some point like some
weird war trophy you better believe it
man like these
well i told them i was like i want those
he's like wow he's like they've been
with me since i was like 12.
like i you know that's like leaving
friends behind and [ __ ]
now you know now i fought to get them
and now that they're sitting on my desk
it's real unnerving i had to like put it
away because i kept looking at it like
those were in my mouth what the [ __ ]
so it's official mark for the first time
in my life i feel i do feel old
i feel like oh i'm 50. this is the kind
of [ __ ] and you know most 50 year olds
don't have to deal with this [ __ ]
i'm sure a lot of people don't have to
go through it but i'm feeling
like you know oh my god like the system
is now starting to break down like it's
it's all entropy from here forward you
know they always tell you by the time
you're 50
you'll have a different doctor for every
body part and [ __ ]
so all we need to do is just keep slowly
replacing you
until you're bionic and then
100 point restoration just done slowly
over time
if they replace every cell of me am i
still me though
um well ghost in the shell according to
that animated film would tell you that
you are
um although you'll be wrestling with
that uh that state of being for the next
four hundred years until you die what's
amazing about mark bernard is he brings
us right back on track i'm sitting here
talking about old-timey oldster stuff
my [ __ ] mouth pain and [ __ ] thank god
mark's like
like ghost in the shell so that most of
our audience is like finally
something relevant to my interest [ __ ]
your mouth we want to talk about wanda
vision
we want to talk about how you're a
cyborg now yeah
yeah this is on brand kids i'm like a
robot i'm like cable
like you know part of me is real and
part of me is not so
hard what was your week like um my week
what the [ __ ] was my week like
my week was a week of handing [ __ ] in i
finished writing
um my spiderman one shot that i'm doing
for
for marvel i'm sorry it's not spider-man
it's peter parker
the amazing sherlock which will tie into
the big hero's reborn event that is
happening in may so
that was this week of writing i was
writing that getting that away
um i've been as as
we are both men of age um and trying to
add ways to
to elongate said life i've been walking
a lot more than i used to be walking
nice you know every every morning i get
out there and do a couple of miles you
know
get one of these sons of [ __ ] man my
wife gave me a fitbit for [ __ ]
valentine's day and i'm obsessed with it
i got the apple watch version does it
make you get up like this [ __ ]
periodically i'm just sitting there and
it's like you have 220 steps to go and
i'm like what
all right and i get up and start walking
the house well it makes me stand every
hour
um and then it'll tell me it's like hey
a brisk walk in 15 minutes will help you
close your exercise range it's like oh
okay cool i'll do that you and me are
the same thing we're being told by
little machines what to [ __ ] do now
that's the beginning of our robot
overlords and i welcome them
wholeheartedly this [ __ ] this is
dr theopolis right here man
i just become twicky that's it but i've
been listening
on my walk to uh to first i was
listening to the sandman audible
um drama with uh james james mcavoy
yeah james mcavoy and uh and kev denning
plays dad um oh does she yeah she's
great
she's great and it's it's it's amazing
and it's so incredibly well done and it
reminded me of my love for the sandman
which i haven't read in a while
but i finished it and i was like oh [ __ ]
what am i going to do now
there was this book i've been meaning to
read called sapiens
or have you ever heard of this thing um
it is basically a history of humankind
from the very very beginning i somewhere
in this room
i have this book and it sat on my desk
for a year and change and my wife would
make fun of me she's like you're never
going to read that and i was like i am
reading it and i got through the first
chapter that's it
scott mogbert recommended it how is it
it's it's pretty phenomenal
especially as an audiobook because i can
see reading it how it can get a little
bit dry
but pretending it's a podcast helps um
but the thing that i found
i'm like maybe a third of the way
through the book now and they're talking
about what
differentiates um homo sapiens versus
every other form
of homo that came before it you know
homo erectus you know and there's
a bunch of different substratas of that
and
ultimately it was the ability to a
gossip to be able to share information
on things that you did not see firsthand
and for that information to be able to
be transferred amongst your
group which allows you to ultimately
engage threats from within get news from
without
the ability to believe in a thing you
didn't see
which leads to the second thing which is
the ability to believe in
a shared fiction in that you know
what is money ultimately money is
you give me this piece of paper i
believe it stands for
five bars of gold i'll never see this
gold
i'll never be able to exchange it for
that gold but i think this paper is
worth something it's a fiction
and and the fact that story was the
engine that allowed us
to move forward as a species um made me
as a storyteller
feel incredibly um sort of warm and
fuzzy inside
you were like i'm important i am the
human race
the [ __ ] thing that i do is actually
what separates us
from you know the the other great apes
of which we belong
you know that like you could if you
believed in christianity you believe in
catholicism
you could see another person from you
know thousands of miles away you've
never met before
and have some common ground and be able
to make some progress together
that we can believe that companies and
governments
and laws and all of those things exist
when they really don't um is what allows
us to progress
as a species and so i found that very um
insightful
and kind of um inspiring in a way it's
crazy i i think about often in kids
for those who are like are you going to
[ __ ] talk about want to visit we're
getting there we're just warming up and
and
actually this probably ties into what
mark's talking about
we share a belief structure our new
religion is one division
and that is something that you can greet
a stranger about
and suddenly have a kinship and whatnot
but i often think about the delicate
social contract and you know new when we
watch the news
and they you know lead with horrifying
stories but if it bleeds it leads
you get the distinct impression like oh
my god the whole world's [ __ ] and like
people are evil and [ __ ]
but the amount of people that exist and
the amount of heinous things that people
have done to one another
are i think it's a widely disparate
number
at the end of the day coming down to
this i can't believe
that the agreements
as you said things that are not real
laws are not real
they're ideas money is not real it's an
idea
that everyone still adheres to that that
people who work in restaurants or food
service industry
aren't like i'm gonna put arsenic in
this and just see what the [ __ ] happens
to somebody like
so much trust goes into all this
and i know everyone shits on the world
and and you know [ __ ] like oh things
are bad and it's always about the
problems
but to me it's like kind of a minor
miracle
that we exist coexist
as well as we do not you and i but the
whole [ __ ]
world like considering how easily
it could just completely [ __ ]
untether if everybody starts going like
well that's not real like i don't agree
with that and we've seen that in the
course of the last year
some people going i don't agree with
that and creating their own reality and
stuff
but i'm just i mean is the one it's
it's never really shouted out enough
that like as bad as we can be as a
species
it's incredible that we're not worse and
we're actually doing
like fairly well um all things
considered
like every every time i go into a movie
theater and it's been a while
but like i'm going to go into the dark
with like
600 strangers and willingly be
distracted from detecting threats by a
thing that's on a screen
and 100 of the time come out on the
other side
you know like and it's not even a
question of do i have to do the
calculations that this is
is you know a risk worth taking it's
just the thing we do
it's a thing we've always done you know
it's the go to comic-con every year
it's like there's 200 000 people here
any of which could want to do the worst
possible thing to a person
and it never happens and hasn't happened
in 40 years like there's been
you know conflict surely there's been
you know fights of course
but like that many soft targets in a
place like that
statistically speaking and for the
record super soft targets my friend
like you're talking about a comic-con
crowd ain't none of them john mcclane
nobody's ready for the [ __ ] threat
but they are super [ __ ] soft if they
come into a con and i'm on the stage in
hall h
i'm like take take me and take all of
them
we are here to do your bidding like
there's no way we fight back
are you kidding me there was one year
where somebody got stabbed
by a protractor in hall age [ __ ]
avengers were there they didn't even do
anything
yeah the social contract that keeps us
all civil and all kind of
moving forward together towards
something resembling
um a happy place um is a remarkable feat
in and of itself
it's crazy um all right
enough philosophizing kids we're going
to
talk about what you came here to talk
about i'm sorry i get this little gnat
keeps coming around here and i don't
kill bugs like i'm not this guy
unless it happened by accident because i
can't make a nat so i don't like killing
[ __ ]
but it's really irritating me where it's
like get out because i'm afraid it's
going to come up with the camera and be
[ __ ] huge and stuff anyway these are
my first world problems [ __ ] all that
ladies and gentlemen
we're here to talk about wanavision as
we've uh been doing every week and uh
before we head into it
next week of course the last episode uh
i read an
article this week that said it's going
to be 50 minutes 5.0
the longest wanda uh wanda vision
episode that has been that's how they're
going to close it out
um we will be doing our show on saturday
next week uh normal uh saturday show
um and we are gonna have a very special
guest i'm not gonna
say who it is but it's incredibly
relevant
to our interests here on the show um
so next week man get ready for the last
episode of wana vision
and then a guest that we have to talk
about it no it's not
elizabeth olsen or paul bettany just to
put that at ease
um it uh all right let's talk about this
week's show
yes [ __ ] incredible uh this was the
first episode
that there's no sitcom framing device
or anything like that uh but we get the
secret origin
of why the sitcom framing device
which was absolutely beautiful it was a
beautiful scene to watch
wanda and her brother and her mom and
dad
enjoying mary tyler moore um
you know it's it's meta because we're
all sitting here enjoying juan division
so as we sit there and watch a family
enjoy a program
it's reflective of what exactly we're
doing
there's a moment you know when of course
she unleashes her chaos
the chaos magic sorry and uh you know
creates
west view as we know it and brings
vision
back you know contradicting what we all
thought you know hayward
insisted that she had stolen the body
and stuff
she created them whole cloth from her
chaos magic
and when she creates him and he says you
know wanda welcome home and stuff
the first thing they do is sit down and
watch tv together easily could have
called this show
someone to watch tv with that's kind of
what it
that's what everybody's looking for in
this life everybody wants somebody
to sit down with and appreciate
something
you know before tv i don't know what
[ __ ] human beings did but
someone who watched tv with is so
[ __ ] insanely important that line hit
me so [ __ ] hard that moment hit me
hard
because like i'm here watching it with
my wife and thinking back
like my entire cross my entire lifetime
all the people that i
sat and watched tv with and stuff and
it's a weird passive act
you know where you're just sitting being
entertained but it creates discussion
it creates i guess a bit of what you
were talking about in the book of
sapiens like
shared belief interest or something it
that profoundly affected me
now that they've put on display that
this
series is absolutely a series about
grief
and dealing with grief um
seeing that the bright spot in her world
goes back to her childhood where she
could just
enjoy tv with her
family really like hit me [ __ ] hard
man
like one of the most heartbreaking
aspects now
of the show yes she lost her brother you
know yes she lost vision and stuff like
that but
seeing like the simple joy that got
ripped away
kind of like you know bruce wayne
watches his parents get [ __ ] killed
in an alleyway or something like that
um hit me in a real hard way when i was
watching the show you know for weeks
people have been theorizing online
that the two people in the commercials
were gonna be her parents
but they were not her parents at all
they went for two different actors all
together
seeing all those dvds when he opened up
the suitcase and [ __ ] like that
took me the [ __ ] back um it's been a
long time since
i saw that mary tyler moore box set like
that
um but just a really beautiful sentiment
of like that's ultimately what we all
want i don't know if that's the world
over i think so
but that person to sit there with
and be quiet while we watch something
else
you know when they go to the scene at uh
the avengers campus
where he comes into her room and you
know she's just like
indicating that he should sit with her
and they're watching uh
uh was it malcolm in the middle or
something um
really like moving you know it just made
me think about all my relationships and
how
sitting down and watching tv or movies
is such a fundamental part of it
do you think it's like that for
everybody is this something that
like i as somebody who's in you know
writing in the arts or whatever
entertainment same with you
i've spent my life staring at the box
the magical mystical box
uh you know it was it raised me in
childhood practically the
television and stuff is it the same for
everybody like
are ever is everybody grooving on this
show because they're like
that's that's me man i too want somebody
to watch tv with
but i think if you if you're watching
this show
you are that person and if it isn't
television specifically
i think there's probably something that
has bonded you and your family or your
significant others
that you can share in silence you know
maybe it's the movies maybe it's sports
maybe it's you know whatever that thing
is but i do think that that
that connection when you can be quiet
with somebody
you know is incredibly important and
like that scene that you're talking
about the avengers campus
like i i i have been occasionally
critical of this show
um and i feel the same way that i feel
about like if i read a if i read a book
and there's
one really good interesting thing that i
take away from that book it was worth
reading
what is grief but love that perseveres
is is worth the entire show
agree that entire segment regardless of
what you think about it regardless of
where you are on the
continuum of value versus whatever
that scene that line that sentiment is
is worth the price of admission
for this you know it is so profound and
it's so beautiful and there's such grace
to it
um and it's the thing that makes vision
special to her
you know as much as we understand now
why sitcoms are her happy place
the reason why vision gets to be in her
happy place is that moment
is that moment when he explains to her
that even though he can't
understand he maybe does anyway
um how heartbreaking was
the deed yeah little heart on it which
ties right back to the calendar
from the first episode and stuff but
that
he had bought them a piece of property
some pla
somewhere to grow old in a place to grow
old in
and on the deed it says wanda maximoff
and the vision and stuff
and you know not taken anything away
from vision because it's an incredibly
wonderful romantic and
deep sentiment but that town
like that's that's the best he could do
for real estate i love new jersey but
like
there are lots of empty plots of land
that he could have picked man
it's really say again he doesn't have a
job
like who's paying his bills true
very true um seeing wanda drive through
the town
and seeing it you know all the cast
members who will eventually become
part of her story and whatnot i know
some people online were like no those
characters meant anything or something
but
you know it's a mystery sometimes
there's misdirect
you know we're all looking for who's
responsible
and now we know it's wanda there is no
big [ __ ] bad
wanda did all this and agatha harkness
who they give us her
origin and it's wonderful um catherine
han just [ __ ]
if if elizabeth olson and katherine hahn
don't walk away with not just emmy nods
but emmys
something broken in that [ __ ] system
man because they're doing grade a
[ __ ] work and her origin story
in salem with her mom and all the other
witches
[ __ ] excellent i'm not sure
that she's a villain you know what i'm
saying like by the time where she's like
at the end of the show where she's like
i know what you are wanda and she's got
the two kids
all of it looks threatening sounds
threatening but ultimately
it sounds like you know after she
ebenezer scrooged
wanda through her life that you know
when she was just like you're dangerous
you know you this is chaos magic and
then of course she said the line that
[ __ ] you know
launched a thousand loads into the air
you know you are the scarlet witch and
the [ __ ]
suddenly you're like oh my god they're
making her name from the comics
like a goal like that it's a thing in
the comics like it's not like the
the scarlet witch you know is a thing
that existed before wanda wanda's just
always been the scarlet witch
but it sounds like they're situating it
as like that's transcendence
like you know you you are you are the
one we saw
the outline in her vision when you know
she was uh
in the hydra base and they were having
her touch the
the mind stone and we saw like
you know the bright and through the
bright yellow light the outline
of what it looks like they're gonna
[ __ ] put on her soon like you know
they're going for it in a big bad way it
feels very much like this is
this is fighting kind of sticking it to
fox a bit which is like
you want to do dark phoenix let me show
you how to do dark phoenix
like let's let's let's make scarlet
witch
the embodiment of something else some
kind of like
the travel goes to the gosarian like
some kind of
weird title position thing of fear
do you think the big well we saw
not this week but last week the book
downstairs in the basement which could
be the dark hole
right dark cold you know has been in
agents of shield it's been referenced
other places
it was going to play a central role in
our howard the duck cartoon that was the
only way for him to get home
was the scatter pages of the darkhold so
which now that i've seen wanda vision if
that is indeed the darkhold
that would have been a reason to kill
howard the duck right in there
um so if that's the dark hole
in marvel comics there's one guy
responsible for the dark cold
and it's not mephisto is a guy named
cathon
you know who goes way back marv uh wolf
wolfman and bill mantello created the
characters like
and they're the ancients and stuff
there's a couple others and whatnot
so i you know i'm still not sure whether
we're gonna get mephisto
um the way everybody keeps going like
it's gotta be mephisto
if it is i'm thinking it's her rabbit
you know mr scratchy because remember
she took that [ __ ]
bug and she turned it into a bird and
then she [ __ ] threw it and then the
rabbit ate the [ __ ]
bird bug thing um and then wanda looks
at it for a second until
you know home girl's like wanda hey pay
attention
i you know maybe the bunny
is gonna turn out to be mephisto or
cathon or something like that
but i don't think we're looking for a
string puller anymore
as revealed in this episode this all
came from wanda it was just like
monica rambo said it's all wanda
so agatha harkness
feels less like a villain to me and more
like
you know somebody obviously has been
around for a couple hundred years
and she is in the magic realm of of
marvel
kind of akin to i mean who would it be
somebody in in you know the marvel
cinematic universe is
like a doctor strange i guess to some
degree also [ __ ] a magician
um i love that they're going into
the magic realm of of mcu of course they
did it with doctor strange but
this is different kind of magic i love
that they're
retconning this is what i was thrilled
with about this episode i've been
reading comics you've been reading
comics for how long
part of the tropes of comics is you got
a bunch of different writers
telling a bunch of different stories
over many many years
so some person writes a story if
somebody else down the road you know is
like well i
the rules of that story [ __ ] with what i
want to do
so i'm going to change it a little bit
i'm going to go back and and change
something in history it's called
retconning of course
they're literally retconning the marvel
cinematic universe
as we speak and it like every time i
watch something i'm like oh my god
like avengers end game the big battle
the enemy like that looks like a [ __ ]
comic book splash page
watching the marvel universe the movies
and the tv shows
to me has been the closest experience
i've had
to reading comics in the 80s and the 90s
when
when i was when it was deep in my
[ __ ] heart and soul when i was
memorizing all this [ __ ]
like it was my religion because even the
trope of
retconning they're bringing into their
work so they're like look we've said
this that she's this and
she was there when the bomb went off and
they waited for it to go off the stark
bomb
now all of a sudden they're telling us
like wanda used the probability hex
and saved their lives this retconning
thrills me not because it's like the old
stories suck
just because it is so much a part
of the comic book history and reading
experience that
they're not only giving us the
highlights the best of stories
mishmashes combos of of great tales that
we've always read
they're not just showing us our
modern-day mythological gods
you know who they make it in possibly
good shape so they can look like the
[ __ ] characters on the page
they're not only playing the emotional
beats um
and the character traits that make us
love these
marvel cinematic universe stars thinking
about
captain america young steve rogers
before he becomes cap
diving on the grenade you know trying to
save everybody moments like that
come straight out of comics and make you
feel like yes yes this is very much
comic book
the retconning though like what they're
doing now with the like
you know what we're gonna add to this
even though you know the story
so far we're gonna add to it and it's
suddenly gonna make [ __ ] better
i saw age of ultron trending on twitter
and i know why because after we watched
that episode like i got my wife to watch
the age of ultron i was like
well in order to get that i was like
that story they told that
in age of ultron with a bomb hit and for
two days we wait for tony stark to kill
us and [ __ ]
and so she was like let's watch that
same thing like this show is so
good is making [ __ ] go back and
re-watch old [ __ ] and it's improving
that old [ __ ]
like it's making it even better so
retconning that's going on in that whole
last episode and this whole series in
fact
that to me is like what's capturing my
imagination right now where i'm like
this is
the purest [ __ ] experience closest
to reading comics as i've ever had in my
entire life they are
nailing this [ __ ] absolutely [ __ ]
nail and i don't mean just wander vision
i mean their entire arc we're living
through [ __ ] history again
it's no wonder i like this [ __ ] so much
there's like the line you know at one
point uh
agatha says to to wanda
like um you know don't be scared you
already lived it once
you know when she's going through the
hydra [ __ ] memory
i've lived all this [ __ ] before when
they show white vision i'm like
west coast avengers when they do this
i'm like oh my god
that was from this story it's like
getting to relive it all again getting
to reappreciate it
like you know on top of having
appreciated the first time
i i don't i think i hopefully it's
coming across eloquently but my god they
are
somehow duplicating the comic book
reading process
at least for me um this is the closest
experience i've had to enjoying some of
these stories
when i first enjoyed them in my teens
and 20s
and for that i'd take i would take this
off but i'm not going to
i take my [ __ ] movies cap off to them
i i the one the one issue that i have
with it's what retcon means
because retcon for me was always
retroactive continuity right which
means like you are you are changing what
happened before to suit what you're
doing now
but it feels a bit like these are less
retcons and more
adding context right like once you have
that scene with her
you know and her brother under the thing
waiting for the bomb to go off
whatever happens there doesn't
invalidate what came before
like it's not changing what you saw that
story is still valid like
me and my brother waited for tilly start
to kill us but what you're adding to it
is that
maybe you didn't know what was happening
maybe you didn't know that you yourself
put a probability x on it
so that it wouldn't go off it's not in
that like that's what i love about it
is that it's finding little pockets of
stories you thought you knew
and adding more information to it as
opposed to changing what came before
and like what came before was like all
right well you know what magneto was
just a magneto for a while
and then they added that you know oh so
now he's their father
like oh that was never there before no
it's a brand new thing and then we'll
add that he's a holocaust survivor that
was never part of the original
configuration it's a brand new thing
i i love being able or i love that
they're taking the opportunity
to dig into the stories that we're
incredibly familiar with as fans
and find new spins on those stories new
pockets of information
that change the context of what we
thought was happening before and i love
that this show is kind of retconning
itself as it goes like the last episode
ended
with itaga all along and this episode's
like no it's actually wanda all along
it wasn't all along wanda's been doing
all of this
you know and so what is what is agatha's
motivation and it seems in
episode previously on motivation is to
find out
how to replicate this magic she wants a
secret to it she wants
this power and what she's learning is
that she can't have it
because wanda is something special
apparently once in a
you know blue moon incarnation of the
scarlet witch
you know and so it's now whatever i do
to your kids i can't get this power
whatever i've done to try and figure out
a secret is not going to be open to me
and now i might be in [ __ ] trouble
because
i'm monkeying with um this woman's
happiness
and uh and she won't have it she also i
feel like
indicated that you know because she was
like you know
because she's like my children she's
like yes your children
and vision all of this you know is chaos
magic they finally said the words out
loud
chaos magic right before she called her
the scarlet witch do you think the
implication
is that like will the boys go on
we know vision won't right will the boys
continue to exist or are they
gonna go away as well we know in the
comics they become
young avengers and stuff but you know
they they're not following
that storyline uh you know um
to the letter so it could be that like
you know what sends her off the edge
other than
everything we've just gone through is if
those kids aren't
[ __ ] real as well because they got
one more episode
to send her to doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
um 50 minutes to i don't know if they're
gonna make her the scarlet witch in this
show or
wait for that movie but like there's
still some heavy lifting to do
uh name here in chat said stop shaming
westview
i didn't think i was but regardless says
we saw at the start of end game that's
how
all cities look right now uh this is
days after end game ended
uh fair enough uh but i i don't think i
was shaming westview and also
westview not a real place kids you can't
shame a place that doesn't [ __ ] exist
i i sort of
i i think that if and clearly
that it passes it's prologue then
kevin feige is always playing a long
game that
for wanda to believe that those kids are
gone is different from those kids
actually being gone
and like if you ever want to spin off
into a young avengers
anything then those kids can be part of
that
formulation um but it's probably
important that wanda thinks that they're
either dead or banished or
whatever the [ __ ] the truth is um
so she can break all the way back do you
think
they're gonna make uh her and white
vision fight
um like somebody in chat was just like
you don't think
she's gonna put her like his personality
in a white vision
i i don't think so i think they set us
up for that with that scene where she's
like i can't feel you
i think they're telling us like he's
dead like he ain't coming back at least
the vision that she knew
and loved and stuff this one inside
westview
um well i mean it depends on what your
thoughts on chaos magic is like if chaos
magic does indeed create
which agatha said you can create a world
whole claw or she said like here you are
making
you know [ __ ] breakfast for dinner
using all this magic
to do that so i wonder if she has
in west view she had the ability to
bring vision back
does do you think this is paul bettany
swan's song is what i'm asking
like do you think when this is done
vision is done i that's the feeling i
got from this episode
is that once this adventure is done like
she is going to come to grips with the
fact that vision is gone forever
there's a beautiful moment where you
know an end game
or infinity war when you know she he's
like what do you feel and she's like i
just feel you
and then they echo it when she's over
his body and she's like i can't feel you
i think that's meant to communicate that
like that's it for vision
um i think the thing that they could do
um again nothing but speculation is that
the end of this show is not going to be
wanda versus white vision
but westfield vision westview vision
versus white vision i think it's a
battle of the visions
and and one of them will die and it's
probably
hers you know it's probably the one that
she created with her chaos magic
slash weird memories of the mind stone i
guess because he'd be
merged yellow and not red from her weird
power
orgasm thing um how awesome is her
whenever she you know
that arch back where she she does this
[ __ ] i can't even do it but she
like completely goes yeah backwards and
she's doing this she's coming out of her
chest
she's done it a few times and like once
in like when she flipped a car or
somebody into a car
in the end game remember she was
fighting [ __ ] uh one of the
the uh black order and then she was like
and she bent backwards and whipped the
chick over her head
here when she was creating west view
like she arched back with chaos magic it
was so [ __ ] metal man
so cool yeah so like i do wonder if
whatever happens
of in between that fight with color
vision
sacrificing himself to save wanda from
what is clearly an agent
of sword being inserted into into her
mind
into her mindscape if something of him
eventually sheds onto the white vision
so she thinks he's gone but then
movies later you realize that no
actually what
what essence she had managed to imbue in
inside the west view vision
has transferred into into the white
knight
where is the west view vision was he he
wasn't really in this episode was he i
don't know
left him where last left him on the road
he flew away um from
darcy when they were in the [ __ ] ice
cream truck or whatever the hell that
was right
i don't think we saw where he landed
so you're right it's going to be vision
on vision isn't it
probably this vision white vision is
essentially ultron
yeah like not the personality but like
that's what the body
was created for like um i love the scene
with hayward
where he was like you know we can't we
have to dismantle the most sophisticated
weapon sentient weapon ever created and
i love that he was just like
you know i know you want to bury him but
we can't just put three billion dollars
worth of
worth of vibranium into the ground like
all of it tracked
like all that but there's one thing he
did
in the scene with her where he suggests
um like you know not everyone has the
power to bring their loved one back
online or i'm sorry back to life
and she was like i can't do that it
almost felt like
he implanted the idea no
there could have been a bit of inception
there and especially you know
he has been lying to various people the
whole time because we did see the
quote-unquote footage
of wanda breaking vision out of sword
which was manufactured at best once we
now get to see
the truth of what she went through which
is she left him there
like she just walked out she didn't
steal his body
you know he's never been on front street
with what happened and what his
motivations are
so it wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me
if maybe
you know instead of a bunny being
mephisto or catholic whatever
that hayward has way more to do with
this than uh than you might have thought
well
then we absolutely did think um such a
nice piece of writing too that like
the the you know the the uh drone
missile
or the drone itself like comes back into
play that they use that magic to [ __ ]
reanimate or what they called like we
just needed you know piece of the source
to bring the the white vision online
which come
remember the cover of west coast
avengers that had [ __ ]
couldn't believe it when they cut to
that i'm like no
like this is incredible it's like
watching my childhood
come to life again i'm so appreciative
to these [ __ ] man because like i
loved this [ __ ] when i was a kid
but you know i'm not going back to
reread that stuff i read it
this is a way to kind of go back through
it again you know and
have it represented in this insanely
entertaining way
um you know which i love comic books
don't get me wrong but like
throwing a score throwing a performance
throwing like twists and turns of a
script
like you know it's if i was going to
redo this material i'm this
i'm happy this is the way i'm doing it i
love this show so much i'm going to hate
to see it end
i don't think there's gonna be a season
two do you um
feige has kind of gone on record he was
at uh tcas over the weekend the
television critics association
has their their winter tour where all
the studios and all the networks will
parade their wares in front of
journalists and say here's what's coming
here's what we're doing so we had his
you know a big sit down with journalists
and he said yeah like we
we know what falconer soldier season two
looks like
we have an idea of what you know loki
season two might look like
but one division leads directly into
like that story continues directly into
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
so we don't know if there's on the far
side of that
a season to a warm division but
by the sound of it probably not because
i think that this particular
configuration of characters and and
location will spend itself out by the
time we're done with episode nine
um let's go back over the greatest hits
so
we get to meet uh uh we get to see the
origin story for ag of the darkness
which was great
uh then it's still trapped in the
basement we realize or
um agatha tells us that it's the rune
spells
that's keeping wanda trapped and she
can't use her magic
agatha knows everything about witchcraft
she refers to wanda as a baby witch at
one point when she does the flashback
um or takes her into her past in sokovia
um and she says like you know what i see
as a baby witch who's going to deal with
years of therapy but not all this
we got to keep going and so they scrooge
it through the rest of
you know big moments in wanda's life um
so we get to see
sokovia we get to see that scene that
was described in age of ultron by her
and pietro
play out beautiful family scene
that's incredibly recognizable at least
to me
like you know that was my family we
weren't we didn't speak sarkovian but
that was my family growing up we
gathered around the tv and [ __ ]
ate food and everybody does that's
[ __ ] america man that's why that's
probably the world
like i always say it's america because i
just grew up here but they got tv
everywhere mark last i heard so i bet
you that's
incredibly universal as people watch
this they're like oh it's not just
like my wife she's she wasn't raised in
this [ __ ] she don't
read the comics so she didn't like read
them when she was a kid or something
like that
but she's watching the show she gets
emotionally invested
because the human element man you know
the best superhuman stories
they they have the super because that's
impressive but it's always the human
element
that's the most relatable we can't
relate to super strength and flying and
[ __ ] but we can relate
to emotional material and stuff and
watching it work on somebody that like
it necessarily shouldn't work on
somebody who
wasn't raised in this [ __ ] or deep in
the genre
us it makes me feel like they're dealing
with this incredibly
universal theme that you know and it's
ironic and because it's meta as [ __ ]
because we're watching it on tv
but they're using this tv show to make a
small statement
about how important [ __ ] tv has been
to us for
forever like you know at least that's i
don't think that's the message of the
show
but that's one of the nice little
byproducts of that if
for i don't know if this sounds right
but
it lets you off the hook a little for
wasting as much time as you did
watching tv in your life because you're
like well look this little girl
she couldn't watch the shows so i
watched them for
we do uh let's see she goes back to
hydra we get to see like her when she
was like
you know making blocks fly in the air
and smashing them like at the end of
one of those flicks in the post-credits
scene um
and we see her you know deal with the
mind stone but whatever happened in that
room didn't happen on video
right so everybody watching in
strucker's organization
they just saw like a blip and then she
collapses to the floor
um but a pretty powerful [ __ ] scene
as well
uh but my favorite of the flashbacks i
love the family one
but i loved her envision because that's
her fallen love that's the most we'll
get to see probably
of her falling in love with vision um
and it's so [ __ ] meaningful you now
understand
why she was drawn to him
like you know he was drawn to her
obviously
but he unlike most people
since he's fairly new as a being
he you could literally sit there with
him and be like here's a show
and walk him through it and [ __ ] like
that somebody to watch tv with
um i love that sequence like i thought
that scene was
really [ __ ] beautiful and she you
know she get he's like do you want to
talk about it and she's like
why would i ever want to talk about it
the only thing that's going to make me
feel better
is if he was here and that's where the
grief you know uh
love persisting line comes out and stuff
really beautiful scene then they take us
you know
to the sword headquarters where we get
to see the full scene
of when wanda went and supposedly stole
vision's body which she didn't do at all
incredibly moving and she walked out of
there
like you know i get it like you can't
just put three billion dollars of
vibranium into the ground
um you know she realizes that what she
was hoping to get from his body
isn't there right there's no connection
there's there's nothing of him left in
that
and so why then she goes to west view
which we're not cracking on it no he's
very defensive of a fictional tenor i
mean
i'd crack on the buick she rents to get
out to west view
well that was crazy it was just like you
know [ __ ] tony stark
drives audis and [ __ ] high-end cars
uh black widow you know drives cap
around and captain america two in a
really hot car
one has got a rental four-door sedan
yeah like you use
some of that chaos magic to make a
better [ __ ] car for yourself we're
just flying
you can actually fly yeah i thought i
found that weird too i was like look at
her just driving around and [ __ ]
i mean i guess you needed to have a seat
in there to have the letter on
so we could see it but yeah that was a
weird poem
and some people were online were like
who put the letter there
i didn't get an impression that a letter
was left in her car she just had that
in her car but i got the impression he
had given that to her
a while or she found it or whatever but
she references
coming back um because remember she
[ __ ] dusted as well
in the snap so when she came back and
she was like you know i came back and
he was he wasn't there his body's gone
they tell me it's here or whatever the
[ __ ]
um it's weird that we're not gonna see
her come back we saw monica come back
but you know also strange that
if she is indeed the scarlet witch that
she was able to be snapped out
of existence as well right well maybe
she does she doesn't know
yet just as the audience didn't know
exactly how powerful
she was um you don't know what i refer
to as dangerous
like not just powerful like that's
that's where you're getting those vibes
for
dark phoenix because it's
you know this is too much power for one
individual to have
that's why i don't read agatha harkness
as a
as a villain right now like she's almost
i wouldn't say a hero but
you know in her origin scene she's like
i can be good and they're like no you
can't
maybe she is trying to do some good
maybe this maybe this ain't about like i
want my
wanda's power for myself she's like you
are [ __ ] up the magical realms or
whatever
[ __ ] that's what i hope it is i hope
she's not a big bad because i love that
character and i hope they keep her going
for like 10 years in the marvel universe
i just i also found myself wondering
when a patient had the time to do
shitty real estate shopping it's like
well you were kind of on the run uh
after
civil war um and then like you died at
the end of
infinity war like when did you buy that
house
slash weird foundation
yeah question you know did you have a
real estate agent
to help you with it or because you're
the greatest ai
i i would like to put my hat in the ring
for that marvel show
the guy who's responsible for selling
properties to all these heroes and [ __ ]
listen mr stark i have this lovely plot
of land in upstate new york
um it's currently zoned for industrial
you can put whatever you want here an
avengers campus yeah totally if you want
he's like that was an old stark
headquarters [ __ ] you that's mine
uh force wielder 69 in chat said agatha
killed sparky so she's dead to me
but sparky's not real or is he chaos
magic
can make something can make a thing but
it can't put a soul in a thing
so is you know
[ __ ] that dog was that dog ever real
you know i mean maybe it was a dog that
was already living in west view
and uh and then got [ __ ] like black
and white wiped
or whatever that was and so maybe it was
a real dog at some point
um dawn h in chat boy man we got to be
careful what we say
she said she didn't [ __ ] but she said i
used to own a buick for nao
you can't we can't can't crack on
anything man like people are like hey
man
my car looks like that hey man my town
looks like that
i live in los angeles lots of places
here
don't look as good as that [ __ ] old
west view that she drove into i could
promise you that
and yes the car was shining but still uh
weasel bomber says vision doesn't have a
soul either but he's real
i i don't know i think vision has a soul
like or had i think he's dead right yeah
um fietro the fact that she called them
fake pie trophy
crow we found out that you know uh
uh what's his name evan um evan peters
is not in fact pietro i wonder if like
is he the bunny are we going to find
that out next week i mean he's got to
come back right
yeah cause you know the last time we saw
him he had to drop on uh on monica
because snoopers got a snoop yeah that's
right so like and they didn't even touch
that they didn't really touch
the monica storyline or anything it was
all agatha
and and wanda and it was a [ __ ]
excellent episode i mean
this was the episode that i think a lot
of us were looking for at episode two
but you don't get to earn this episode
until you go through the whole [ __ ]
journey
yeah although i would also say that you
could you could have slid this episode
around
in the order a little bit like you
wouldn't want it as early as two
to your point like that's probably too
soon but it could have been four
it could have been four or five you know
and so
that you'd have enough time to build the
mystery and then pay off what the
mystery is about
and then deal with the repercussions of
of all that stuff
um but that's that is a tiny pick to
knit
knit to pick matthew robarge and chad
says quit casting the bunny
geez come on man that's part of the fun
of the show is trying to figure [ __ ] out
apparently
a lot of us been spinning wheels for no
damn good reason because not everything
is
is a thing um
and i think that's by design i think you
know some of it is you know what
if people latch on to this and want to
spin their theories like go for it like
we know the story we're telling we know
what means what and what doesn't
and otherwise the rest of it's just
[ __ ] fun
uh michael schaff's in chat in chat said
agatha used sparky to show wanda
that she can't and shouldn't bring
things back from the dead
i like that i hope that's true you get
that impression
uh could be except you know she hasn't
you know like she didn't actually
resurrect dead vision into live vision
she just created a similacrum vision
of her own true this um
uh like hodar said has have kevin and
mark uh discussed superman reboot yet no
kids we're still just
on juan division we'll get to the news
yeah we'll get to the news but this is
right now
uh lukang says agatha and fietro
uh was a crystalline possession and that
she didn't she didn't agatha said fiat
was a crystalline possession that she
didn't do necromancy
so who did she possess or is it like a
hard like construct but magic
meaning who is fietro or what is vietro
well what is featuring unclear
you know it could just be a [ __ ]
paperboy could be you know
some weird animated you know magic
construct
jwt cosplay in chat says it's all over
when white vision speaks with ultron's
voice next episode if they did that
have [ __ ] nuts oh my god i would love
that give me that spader back
uh charles pierce says fiatro is the
beekeeper that's an interesting theory
um jason joseph monterosso says why is
fietro
who's fate what is fajr y
um this is one of the reasons i love
this show is because uh you get to hear
from a bunch of people who have like
this is this is clever it's zayden too
says visions initials are tv
you think that's do you think they're
aware of that that can't be that's
that's
what a great observation but uh joey
shalom said
the bunny is victor garber
maybe we'll be able to get him on the
show absolute jeff's kiss for that
delightful um all right
which uh did we cover enough wanna
vision i feel like we did man i feel
like we did and i think you know next
week
uh will be our last chance
to to see and or talk about one division
uh space tiger says the bunny is clearly
ebony i've seen this uh
theory online um uh you know uh
agatha has a cat black cat normally
named ebony
uh some people online are theorizing
that ebony
phonetically broken down is uh a
a bunny
sure that seems that seems like deep
cuts like i i
that might be reading something where
something isn't yet because you could
just do a cat
we're gonna hide this cat um
all right theory kevin mayhe says agatha
is a tutor
guide for wanda to unlock her true
potential as scarlet witch
that's what i'm hoping i'm hoping that
she's she's more of a
coach and you know even though she's got
her kids by those magical
[ __ ] strings i'm hoping that she's
i'm not gonna say like a good guy but
like you know
somebody in chat said she's like the
female loki i'd take that
yeah although i think that there's the
version of
the coach that's trying to get her to
become the scarlet witch at the behest
of somebody awful
who needs the scarlet witch and that
power you know so
is is she like the herald of galactus
in a way which is like oh
i need this power on this plane to
unlock x
because x is where mephisto lives or
whatever that is
i need to usher in the coming of the new
age and to do that
we need a scarlet witch i want to buy
your version of
wanda visions last episode right now
the zip code for the map in wanda's car
says matt dot's go
is for annandale new jersey
isn't that weird uh isn't that also
where um
where that military base was where cap
has to go
um in uh in winter soldier
i think you actually might be right
about that raphael roygan daniel says
wanda saw her mother natalia maximov in
the chamber scene
did he did she i don't recall
but i don't i thought she saw a vision
of the scarlet witch
yeah of herself
um or possible future yes um
everyone's saying that james spader is
listed somehow in credits or something
like that
um that he is gonna do a voice this week
what do you think the odds are um
i i will say nothing because i don't
know nothing
and i don't want to get lambasted for
[ __ ] offering some
bit of information that is purely
conjectural or theoretical
um it would be super cool but then again
nobody knows where the credits are for
next friday's episode because they won't
know until it airs
uh cataracts uh geeky people's points
out cataracts make your eyes white
the project to build white vision was
named cataract in last week's episode
yes that was very clever i'm very
they're they're having a good time
over at that show and we'll probably be
uncovering little easter eggs for a long
time to come i would i would imagine
um man oh man i think i'll work my whole
life
and i'll never make something as good as
this
you know it's just so well done they're
doing the lord's work with the show mark
i i'm i'm happy it's ending but i'm
unhappy it's ending but i'm happy
because
it's going to lead us someplace else and
whatnot and just like vision said in age
of ultron
a thing isn't beautiful because it lasts
you know
so this has to end and i'm when it does
you know but at the same time i'm happy
it existed
what do they say about grief they're
like don't be sad it's over
be happy it ever happened um and i
i'm happy this [ __ ] happens man this
inspires me
as a storyteller you know very rarely
can a storyteller be entertained
by other people's stories because you
have a drive yourself
um that's why i i cling to [ __ ] like
this and i
raise up high the things that do move me
because
you know at when you could [ __ ] trick
the trickster
you know hats off when you could [ __ ]
you know when the magician doesn't know
how you've done the trick that's
that's that's about as fantastic as you
could be at the job and stuff so
i love it i'm going to miss it um but i
i love that it existed at all it's it's
made the last uh
you know [ __ ] two months wonderful
but it's also kind of like it personally
it's given me a way into these marvel
movies with my wife
who couldn't have given a [ __ ] and now
like literally this morning i showed her
the [ __ ] cat jumping on the grenade
scene on youtube she was like what's
that
and i was like that's from the first
captain america captain america the
first avenger she's like we haven't
watched that and i was like
so personally it's delivered you know uh
my wife to the marvel universe so i'll
always be appreciative
of it for that as well excellent yeah i
i i look forward to your
ongoing binge with jen like you know
what let's let's go all the way back to
the beginning let's let's let's just
marathon this slowly but surely
design one of these will make her want
to watch more truly
sally beauchamp just said something
cathon theory
might tie into the eternals do you think
any of this i mean
i mean it all is going to tie in in some
fashion or another
right on man i didn't think of that
um scott hawk says spader makes sense as
the actor that betany
wanted to work with you know paul
bettany was like there's a cameo coming
up
for with an actor i've always wanted to
work with and you know some people
online are like maybe he met himself
because he's gonna be fighting himself
but um
scott hawks is saying maybe it's spader
that he's referencing to
um and what does this part say
[Music]
um it's i'm sorry i'm getting
everyone's got great theories kids i'm
looking at your chat comments
and they're so [ __ ] good like that's
that's how good this show is it inspires
great conversation just like mark was
talking about you know with sapiens at
the beginning
it's it's fires people's imaginations
you know it's not even the detective
work that we keep doing like the cat was
like stop trying to cast the bunny and
[ __ ]
we can't help it that's how engaging
this [ __ ] is that it's like
i'm gonna fill in the blanks until they
fill the blanks in for us
um yeah this better win a bunch of
[ __ ] awards man
uh all right kids that wraps up our
wanda vision
chit chat for this week uh hopefully you
found it
illuminating i think we've covered
everything once again
give elizabeth olsen all the emmys right
now
give katherine han all the enemies right
now what do you think of her costume i
liked seeing the agatha outfit it was
dope yeah that's pretty sweet
i mean the only thing she don't have is
the white hair they let her keep like
dark hair
yeah she she did look full on grey
gardens and i appreciated that
so true um all right kids next week
final episode of wanda vision on
thursday at
midnight and [ __ ] and then on saturday
when we do our show
we're gonna have somebody to talk to who
might be able to tell us a bunch of
stuff about
about wandavision but for now
uh we're done with wanda vision now we
come to that part of the show ladies and
gentlemen where we rely on the muscles
of the man to my over there [ __ ]
wherever he is
that guy that guy but i can never do it
like it's like
it's a mirror there you go
uh mr mark bernard before he was a
creative force before he's writing
marvel comics that's two at least he's
got
under his belt right now that i know of
if not more uh before he
was uh working on tv and and movies and
[ __ ]
and other things that we can't talk
about um he was a news man
a newshound if you will a journal and he
speaks their language kids he
knows the language of the press and
that's why every week we ask mark
bernard and go out there and find out
what's happening in the news he traps it
brings it back alive
and we get to talk about it right here
mr mark bernard is going to give you the
news kids
indeed um the the big story this week
um which broke as seems to be the case
relatively late in the week
is that jj abrams and and writer
ta-nehisi coates
are doing a superman movie
like you know jj i think one of the
reasons why
he moved his bad robot production
company to warner brothers was to get to
play with the dc universe toys
um i think there is floating around the
internet somewhere
an old jj abrams superman script that he
wrote back in the day like he's
he's had an affinity for this character
for a long long time the one where
krypton survived
he wrote a script where you know the
baby goes off but krypton did not blow
up and so kryptonians came to earth
to like take over and stuff like that um
so yes he's so far just producing but
ta-nehisi coates if you're not familiar
with ta-nehisi
um is uh is one of the biggest brightest
intellectuals working today he was a
columnist for the atlantic
he wrote um an amazing piece of
journalism called the case for
reparations a 20 000 word
sort of just deep dive into what
reparations for slavery means
which then would help inspire dana
lindelof to do watchmen
um he's also written books like the
beautiful struggle and between the world
and me which was somewhat memoirish
but he also more pertinent to our
conversation
um relaunched black panther um back in
2016
which was not he became a comics guy
maybe he you know
according to him he's always been um but
this was the first time he actually got
to
to make the things that he was in love
with since he was a kid
and so sort of relaunched black panther
it blew up it was not the
cause of the black panther movie that
marvel would then make or even the
instigation for them to put him in in
civil war
but ryan coogler often referred to
tanahasi's
black panther run as an inspiration and
that currently he's writing uh captain
america
for marvel and so they are 100
digging into superman and what makes
superman tick according to sources
the project is being positioned as a
black superman story
um given you know for any number of
reasons not the least of which i think
is that
you know michael b jordan has wanted to
to play superman for a long time
two years ago they were talking about
this and uh
it looks like maybe we're coming up on
the the dawn of the black superman
something that we've talked about on
this show
a few times like i remember that one of
the most illuminating conversations we
ever had about like why don't they do
black batman is when you were like
because generational wealth is a white
thing
i was like oh [ __ ] right what can they
do with the story
of an outsider who doesn't look like
you know the standard version of the
outsider that we've been
given i it's it opens up a treasure
trove of
storytelling possibilities that
you know haven't really been open before
there's a different experience to view
this entire
kal-el from krypton a different prism to
view it through
i mean there's there's there's there's
two paths right there's
we are going to do kel-el we're going to
do the traditional like he will land in
kansas or someplace there abouts he will
be clark kent
but he will be you know he will have
dark skin which
krypton as we've seen from media in the
last 30 or 40 years is not a completely
homogeneous
you know ecosystem there are black
griptonians white ketones
i'm sure there are you know other hues
on the on the chromatic scale of
kryptonians
um so yes there's nothing to say that
this person has to be
if he's going to be clark and has to be
white um and then there's the the valzad
version of it from
you know tom taylor and uh i think
nicolas scott
um did a run on earth too where they
introduced you know i think his name was
calvin ellis when he
you know whether then be an earthling
but
it's a completely different version of
that story in which you know a black ex
kryptonian still lands on earth and
still puts the s on his chest
and and fights crime as superman um
there are virtues to both of those for
sure you know
one of them pisses off less people i
think
um for the same reason that people were
furious that like why is heimdall
black like there were no black vikings
except that there totally were
um but uh but so
for me like i kind of want him to be
clark kent
you know like i kind of want to just
like what does that story look like
through a different prism
you know what does what does the story
of an alien look like what does the
story of adoption look like what does
the story
of finding yourself and being different
look like
you know if the original superman mythos
is
is ultimately a commentary on being
jewish in america
um you know why couldn't it also then be
tweaked a little bit to be a commentary
on being black in america
um and being something that people are
afraid of
unless you unless you bury that identity
under something else
um yeah i i could go either way i see
the virtues in either way but i
i am incredibly excited um at the
prospects of jj wrapping his arms around
it
and somebody with a brave assassin tana
has he's giving it some uh
a good thing um you know uh naturally of
course there are a bunch of people
online who are like come on don't
[ __ ] do that do
just make it an earth 2 story or
something like that um
somebody in the chat they went by fast
but they said
uh this type of tokenism is why people
turn to the right
i i personally feel like these
characters can be interpreted any number
of ways
i know some people are like what does
this mean for henry cavill i you know i
think henry cavill was done from what i
understand
um you know zack snyder seems to be done
they're not
they're not talking they what they call
it a creative cul-de-sac it's not like
they're going to continue or something
like that
so we already have two supermans going
right now
we have the snyder vs superman henry
cavill and now
uh the cw superman and lois superman um
was named tyler huckler so
you know it's there's room for plenty
of interpretations of this character and
just cause they make a movie doesn't
mean like you can't
appreciate the other ones or there won't
be another one like you know you know
this [ __ ] kids
wait ten minutes there'll be another
[ __ ] superman right after that and
stuff
um i'm i'm all for it i i'm
i'm look i'm gonna see it it's not like
i'm like i'm against this or i'm not
gonna see it
i can't wait to see uh what they do with
it but i don't think anybody should feel
like angry it's not nobody's getting rid
of anything it's just
you know comics have done alternate
stories all the time
uh this seems like it could be very much
that
but i don't know to me it's it's like oh
this will be fun i haven't seen this
this will be new um so i
you know and jj i i like jj
you know he's totally trustworthy when
it comes to like making mass
entertainment
um and you know um how do you say his
name tahasi
tanahasi tanahasi um
you know you couldn't ask for a more
erudite author on a [ __ ] superman
movie
they hired my dumbass to write superman
in 96. at least they're going up
at least they're like look we got an
intellectual to write at this time
um i'm all for it i can't wait to see it
but
do they do if it is indeed black
superman and they haven't
said that yet but if they do do black
superman is it the entire universe
like is it black lois lane black lex
luthor or is the story more compelling
if it's
you know white lex luthor
or asian lex luthor or whatever i mean i
feel like
you know everything is up to to a
certain amount of litigation like once
you
once you crack that part open and say
you know what
this is how we're taking you know clark
kent slash black superman
and if it is val zod then there's also
no no saying that we're coming into
conflict with luther's and lanes
and all that stuff um
but you know i i i sort of think it's a
little bit more interesting if you just
change the one thing
and let everything else remain the same
and what that thing the dominoes that
that starts to topple
you know and if dc has done nothing else
they've taught us that in the coming
years the multiverse means everything
um and so there's no saying whatsoever
that if they make the superman movie
with michael b jordan as clark kent that
you also cannot have another superman
movie with henry cavill as clark kent
you know and there could not be some
kingdom come version of this at some
point down the line
where you get lots of different
supermans on the same stage at the same
place
think about this i mean depending on
where they start their story obviously
like when we they made superman dick
donner made superman in the 70s
clark kent grows up in the 50s and the
60s
in that movie who know you know when we
did uh what they did
uh man of steel clark kent grew up in an
era that was more recognizable to us
maybe 80s or 90s or something like that
so if they do this one and if they
indeed if they indeed do black superman
does he still land in rural kansas
and are the kents white because that to
me is an interesting [ __ ] story
where it's like you know it's one thing
for two old people to find a baby and
start passing it off as their own
at least if that kid you know matches
their race nobody's gonna question it
that that's an interesting wrinkle to a
story to be like where'd you guys get a
kid and by the way
why doesn't that kid look like you yeah
like i think at that point the lie that
everybody was willing to believe for the
kent
you know where i'm sure their friends
knew like
she wasn't pregnant well
they lived rurally mark like on way out
there on a farm so it's not like they
went to town a lot
so he could have gotten pregnant but
yeah it'll be
that to me is like that's an interesting
wrinkle to a story
where it's like i've not seen that
before they've never done you know they
the the uh
is clark different aspect of the
superman story
usually kicks in when he saves you know
pulls the bus out of the water or saves
some kid or whatever the [ __ ] and then
you know his dad's like don't [ __ ]
show your powers
at least the current incarnation um
it'll be interesting to see like
how this if if they indeed do black
superman
how it gets to unpeel
the onion in different ways and layers
than we've never seen
before i mean it totally feels like
there's opportunities for new and
different kinds of drama
within that same thing because yeah to
your point if it is still two white
people from kansas
who who have to adopt and go through
whatever machinations of adopting
you know a black infant you know
and what happens when this black kid has
power you know and what happens
in the you know a world of kansas and
you know i am not going to cast a broad
brush
on what kansas is like but it is middle
of america and
you know and again still not casting a
broad brush but it is
it is a different experience to be black
in the middle of america than it is to
be black on the coast of america
we're going to get a lot of [ __ ] they're
like they're [ __ ] on west view
they're [ __ ] on kansas
we're not [ __ ] on anything we're not
shooting on anything but you know
what what it is like to have to to
to hide your glory you know to a certain
degree
and and you know hammer it to the ground
and pave it down so that you are not
somebody that people pay too much
attention to
and what it means for people to pay too
much attention to you when you're black
versus white
you know and what that they can't harm
clark kent but what that then does to
the kents
you know suddenly becomes an issue of
like blowback like holy [ __ ] like
they can't shoot you they can't lynch
you
so they're going to come and burn the
farm and then what does that mean
you know and then what is that the guilt
that then lands on clark kent
when he realizes that bad things will
happen to his family because of him
like is that what drives him out of
smallville at the end of the day
you know less i'm just going to work for
the planet or i got to do my walk about
to learn who i am
take it i got more of these i'm going to
keep giving them to you if you keep
writing them
like that these are all excellent points
and this mind you kids this is just
some conjecture from some [ __ ] fans
not even close to the process imagine if
you're in the middle of that process
the question you're asking now the
[ __ ] story plot points they're going
through
here's how and i'm not saying they
should do this but here's how they make
it
better for everybody for the people that
are like superman's gotta be white
just call [ __ ] else worlds man start
a whole series
within the marvel universe of like not
marvel universe dc universe
dc elseworlds and then here's your
superman dude
batman you just do do everything that
they do in elseworlds now in the book
under like this umbrella of of movies
now i'm not saying
do that because i don't want you [ __ ]
with my mythology
it just seems like you know it would put
everybody at ease plus it would
introduce
a concept that they've got that the
competition doesn't have
like closest thing marvel has is what if
and we're about to see that [ __ ] in
cartoon form
if dc or warner brothers was like we're
gonna do a whole series of movies that
are just elseworlds under that brand
name and [ __ ]
that's that's a whole new kettle of fish
man more money be made there and it
sounds like they're heading in a
direction similar in as much as
you know the flash is all about the
multiverse and if we've got michael
keaton batman mixing with ezra
miller flash clearly they're they're
doing some adventurous things but
there's a there's a case to be made for
just doing a whole series of elseworlds
movies
and and and embracing something they
created years ago
in order to not upset fan bases when
they were like we want to tell a
different version of this story
yeah i mean it it provides cover um
in a way that that might make it easier
for some to swallow that pill
the question is whether or not they feel
like they want to
to hide behind that cover it's there for
them if they want it
but there's also a statement to be made
in this is this version of superman for
today
you know and this is he will have the
big giant warner brothers dc comics logo
and all of the resources
it's like you know okay well static shop
is going to be on hbo max is a direct to
video premiere
it's like well yeah i get it but at the
same token
you could just make that a real ass
movie um
as you kind of should but
who the hell knows man who the hell
knows all all i'm saying
is that it seems like there's a ton of
opportunities
to to ring some new wrinkles out of this
particular drama
which is a story as old as time i
i i think like the superman origin story
has been told
almost as many times as like the jesus
origin story
stolen from moses mind you indeed
it is it is at its best you know a
religious parable
um and so we know it so well so to be
able to make that a little bit different
i think is something worth embracing so
power to them
furman 67 in chat says what if preceded
elseworlds by almost 20 years yes that's
absolutely true nobody was saying that
elseworlds came close what if has been
around for a long long time i was just
saying they both have their own kind of
thing but yes marvel did it first long
before dc however
dc had a multiverse before marvel so
they were doing what if stories like hey
what if superman was married to lois
lane
they just called it earth 2 or 3 earth
4.
so similar sensibility to the what-if
stories wouldn't you agree
absolutely absolutely and i just i won
an argument i didn't know i was having
with a stranger on the internet
well you know that's uh 21st century
life my friend
um yeah man that's uh that's i'm i'm
look whether or not you're like uh
hey man i'm black superman i don't know
if i want it i want it
what i'm happy to hear is that dc
engine cranking up with
you know jj's big fat deal went over
there
and like mark said it was chiefly we
imagined to play with the action figures
so it's nice to know that that machine
is starting to ramp up because once he
gets going
he's a [ __ ] factory that guy you know
and if this is what he's gonna do which
is like
you write this you write this you write
start handing out assignments
you're going to start seeing more
development and
more production because you know are
they ever going to say no to a jj abrams
they're paying them
a ridiculous amount of money for that
deal i assume anything he walks in the
[ __ ] doors with and goes oh this is
what i'm settling on they're going to be
like
go thank you
i'm excited and curious superman did you
watch
superman and lois the cw premiere this
one i have not i missed it did you
and then watch the whole show but i
watched uh they put up the first five
minutes
on youtube or something like that and so
i i watched it
um it looks good like i look forward to
watching him right now i'm in a marvel
place with my wife so i don't want to
disrupt it by being like we swap out
some superman and have her be like what
so uh you know i'm not going to
introduce it to her right away
uh but i've yet to watch it here but
from everything i've read
you know clearly they spent the money on
it
um and clearly the story they're telling
which i
initially you know when i first heard
about i was like why would you do that
like why are you going to
have them be married and have kids and
[ __ ] actually sounds pretty damn
interesting what they're doing with it
hmm yeah i'm curious i'm curious i
missed it
i missed it on it's a premiere and so i
better
find out where it's streaming i'm hoping
hbo max is that place
hulu um cw shows aren't on hulu like the
next day i think aren't they
i i don't know like it's it's hard to
tell anymore start to guesstimate
where the uh the natural sort of exit
strategy would be like could be cw
could be the cw app could be a hulu
could be
yeah so i'll just dear computer
find for me superman lois trevor golding
in chat said superman lois was amazing
movie quality uh kenneth cerak says it's
solid
uh krypton says best superman in like
the last 20 years on tv
um so yeah people it's on the cw app
they're telling us
um so i guess it's not on hulu mark it's
on cw's website right now says mw the
cool
thank you the cool um so yes we have to
catch up on that uh but i did watch the
opening scene and he
uh has like a green pt cruiser that he
that flips off and he catches it and
rests it down
and it did look like the cover of you
know action comics number one of him
holding the
green car and they gave him the old logo
for his first appearance i guess or
whatever in metropolis in the flashback
opening
and um you know the kid's like wow a
nice suit and he's like you like it my
mom made it for me and takes off
[ __ ] adorable absolutely adorable
it's safe
that's a bad outfit
what um what uh what else we got in the
news
um the other thing uh not the other
thing but
the next thing on the rundown is you
know it's small
really in the in the grand scheme of
things but we finally got a title
for the next spider-man movie um
revealed in the most adorable way
it was very adorable yeah you know we're
young tom holland talking with zendaya
um you know and and and the other guy
um whose name escapes me um but like i
could keep a secret whatever spoiled
anything like i'm
my mouth is like a steel trap and then
they walk by the blackboard or the
the whiteboard that's got you know all
the various titles on it including
you know highlighted circled a thousand
times spider-man no way home
um to correct charlie huffman said in
chat it's the fleischer
superman symbol not his first one my bad
you're absolutely right it's the
fleischer s
that they put on his chest i'm sorry i'm
50 and i've had oral surgery on friday
and i've not smoked weed in four days so
bear with me
my mouth has holes in it that it got
literally stitches between every one of
my [ __ ] teeth uh
bear with me i forgot you're absolutely
right it's the flasher one
uh back to what you were saying mark yes
spider-man no way home
um including uh on that white board if
you look very closely there's lots of
little like hexes on there
like who is there going to be hex magic
and spiderman
way home is this also going to in some
fashion deal with
magic in in our universe and it seems as
if
this big next phase is a magic phase
well it said no way home indicates
that like he is lost in the multiverse
um or
also indicates like you know how do you
get back after this mysterio thing
but i think it's definitely multiversey
more than anything else
um which is like uh you know tom
holland's been out there saying like i
we just shot one of the greatest action
sequences
of all time he's been saying high praise
for the movie but you know of course
it's not like he'd be sitting in there
going like
we're making the biggest piece of [ __ ]
but what he's all
everything he's been saying has been
very encouraging not like we needed
encouragement like what if this john
watts can't pull it off
he's made two wonderful spider-man
movies i'm sure this one
will be a swan song would be equally as
wonderful if not better than the
previous two
because my man's then heading across the
street to work on ff for heaven's sake
so he's got the goods man he's got the
goods
uh i can't wait to see this movie yeah
and apparently it'll only be in theaters
in december
december 17th of this year of this year
so when is doctor strange um
i'm not sure i think dr strange is 2022.
so spider-man is happening before doctor
strange
yep i thought oh wow i thought doctor
strange was going first
and march 25th 2022 is dr strange
multiverse of madness
oh my god so when wanda vision's over
we're going to have like a [ __ ] year
without wanda
um yeah unless she also appears in
eternals
yeah or sprinkled into spider-man far
from home
if there's nothing that [ __ ] yeah i mean
we also get
at some point this year we get black
widow we get shang chi and we get
eternals
um and spider-man so that's four
like making up for lost time for marvel
movies in this calendar year
that's that's a reason right there for
them to cure this covet [ __ ] right away
we got [ __ ] four marvel movies coming
man let's go
let's go you know on top of loki
and uh and falcon winter soldier which
the new spots for falcon and the winter
soldier
show baron zemo in the mask
i went nuts i was so like now they
showed him carrying the mask but then
they show him in the mask firing a gun
and [ __ ]
it takes so little mark to make me happy
putting him in that mask made me so
happy seeing that pink [ __ ] ski mask
i was like
give me that zemo oh he's going full
zemo
right yeah none of this [ __ ]
i don't have a mask zemo and he was good
daniel bruhl was really good in that
movie
his performance is so good that he made
up for not having that [ __ ] mask but
let's be honest if you bring him back
put the [ __ ] mask on him and they did
it they did it right by it can't wait
you don't go have zemo you gotta go full
zemo old zemo
um what else we got um let's see disney
plus announced a couple of premiere
dates
um also as part of that tca um
big roll out they announced that star
wars the bad batch
will premiere on may the 4th
very very appropriate oh look at that
how that's yeah that's
star wars day that's some planning um
and then the series premiere of loki
won't be far behind as it hits on june
11th
i'm in i'm i'm honestly i'm i was
most excited about wanda vision um
they're getting me more excited about
falcon the winter soldier with that zemo
[ __ ]
and uh loki i need more information on
of course i'm there for tom hiddleston
he's wonderful that character is great
but uh i you know there's it's not on my
radar yet i know it's coming but i'm not
like
i will i'm sure once i start seeing
longer spots and whatnot
yeah um it does make me wonder
you know what the likelihood of black
widow
being a disney plus premiere or at least
a disney plus
and theatrical simultaneous premiere
um because there's a bit of a gap
between i think we're getting
falcon winter soldier um like in three
weeks
i think ultimately it's coming like end
of march middle of march
and then we're not getting loki until
june 11th and it seems as if there's a
world in which
there's a bit of a marvel depression in
the middle there
that you could you could like i don't
know maybe middle of may
end of may you could get uh you can get
a sweet ass black
widow movie in there i've seen some
online reports
of uh you know it could be dummied up
doctored schedules but
there was one that indicated that black
widow might be a may
disney plus release but you know that
could easily be an
online fake or something like that it
could be uh but new york is
falcon in the winter soldier gonna be 10
episodes or six
six so that takes you from when does it
begin march 19th so that takes you
two of those episodes take you to
june no to march to april
and then you get another four that takes
you through to may that it takes you
right up to june
so it might only be like a slim period
between
falcon and the winter soldier and loki
did you say june
well enough if a falcon winter soldier
starts in march
would be march and then the end of april
and then may
oh that's right i forget that i [ __ ]
left me out so may would be the place
where you could put
black black widow if you wanted to um
because
new york is going to start opening
theaters new york city at 25
capacity there is still no word yet on
la um or san francisco
i'm not sure where chicago is but just
thinking about the population density of
theaters that will make this studios
comfortable
to begin putting movies in theaters and
have that be part of the the revenue
driver
don't know when we're going to be there
um and i don't know if we're going to be
there
you know vis-a-vis the vaccination rates
slash covid you know transmission rates
going down
whether or not it will just at some
point make sense for them to have to
pull that trigger to keep this train
moving the way they want it to be moving
it's like well one of these is going to
have to be a disney plus premiere
and that one is probably going to be
black widow
um i'm down my why you know since we've
been watching these marvel movies at one
point she said to me she's like is there
a black widow movie i was like it's
funny you should ask
one they just haven't released it yet
and we watch the trailers and stuff
but do you think since
you know it's a story set in the past
does it have any relevance for the
ongoing marvel cinematic universe black
widow um
i mean it's easy for it not you know
it's easy for it to be a sort of
to to borrow your phrasing before a
cul-de-sac of story which is
you know we know that that you know
scarlett johansson's black widow that
natasha romanov
is dead in a in the present future of
these stories
and so like maybe you can set up a bad
guy you know maybe there's a villain who
can kind of spill forward maybe there's
a
you know some kind of doohickey or or
mcguffin
uh that can that can spill forward but i
don't i don't know quite how
well it could tie in with current
ongoing story
um mark depreal says at disney investor
day they said black widow would come out
in may
and then dick mcwillie great name oh
yeah
may is a huge month in the uk as it's
when disney plus
launched so i expect them to have some
content to keep subs
i mean if they've launched it's called
what disney star or
something like that star is where
they're putting all the the uh sort of
adult-y stuff i think the
the fx stuff and some of the fox library
that's a little bit more mature is
disney star
but yes dick mcwillie and uh fat black
patrick swayze
should form some kind of team like
harley davidson and the marlborough man
i would watch that uh i would watch that
adventure film
uh matthew lawton is saying soul the
dragon was good
uh a lot of people like you guys
watching yet i still haven't watched
soul the dragon so that's something i'll
do this week
yes we've been bad at our homework yeah
yeah well i mean to be fair we've been
doing
you know there's there's been a lot to
cover um division is really just
[ __ ] taking all the all the [ __ ]
warm water man it's just
it's where you want to be i've been
living for thursday nights i'll be
honest with you
i had to go get my oral surgery friday
morning but
i still stayed up till [ __ ] midnight
watching
like waiting for wanda to come on
because i was like this is the last good
thing's gonna happen if
before they [ __ ] cut my gums open and
[ __ ]
and i had to watch it without wheat
which been a rough couple of days for
you man
again it's not like a horrible thing and
i'm not fiending or something like that
but it's just such a
colorless world you know what it's like
it's like
eating spaghetti without spaghetti sauce
where you're like well
you know i could do it but why would you
do it
why wouldn't you want to put sauce on
them
with my spaghetti sauce smoking musk
[Music]
come here and get some of this seasoned
food a lot of people are asking me about
doing edibles and [ __ ]
um i i can't
my teeth like that would mean eating
something there's sprays i could use and
[ __ ] but i'll be honest with you
i'm now i'm just curious to see how long
i could go you know every once in a
while like i'm big into fasting so i'll
[ __ ] go like five six seven days
without eating just to see if i can
accomplish it and [ __ ] like that
now i'm in this place where i'm like let
me see how long i can go without weed
just to shut up
any [ __ ] remaining critics who are
like man human [ __ ] weed or whatever
the [ __ ]
um i'm just just taking it as far as i
can but i honestly so far i'm not like
crawling the walls or anything like that
proving once again
you cannot physically get addicted to
marijuana
like because if anyone was it would
probably been me
but like four days and i don't even
[ __ ] think about it and it's not like
they got me on
pain meds that make it better the only
thing i'm taking for for this is just
three advil
so it's it's not like well they got me
something else man so
i'm excited life in a crisp fashion and
you know yeah you're like the forest
gump of consumption
you're just like i'ma just run jenny
like one day i started running and i
just never stopped
oh god i wish i'd be all forrest gump
thin and [ __ ]
in shape but your version is like i just
decided to stop eating one day
and i just figured i'd keep going just
to see
human endurance like what i'm what's
what i'm capable of
but um yeah it's uh i don't know why
anyone chooses not to smoke weed
what's wrong with what's wrong with
everybody mark which what's wrong
with you why are they eating their
spaghetti without sauce that's what i
need to know
uh what other news we got um amazon
is currently developing uh a live action
gi joe
tv series wait amazon or paramount plus
amazon because paramount plus came out
with this week with a bunch of
announcements and i that
isn't gi joe a paramount movie it you
know
the production companies behind it are
paramount television studios
e1 and skydancetv are all in
in bit on this you know some of it could
be you know
we talked you know a while ago about why
warner brothers
when when it was you know first starting
hbo max and the sandman
was the show that they were going to
make the sandman is a netflix show and
not an hbo mac show
and one of the reasons why that happened
was at the time
warner brothers was cash poor they had
just laid out
hundreds of millions of dollars in
overall deals to keep greg berlanti at
the studio to get jj to side of the
studio
and they just didn't have any more money
to spend on [ __ ] they needed something
on the incoming column and not the
outgoing column
and so i think that's one of the reasons
why they let sandman out of the gate
is because netflix paid them a boatload
of [ __ ] money
for the rights to make that show um so i
wonder if this is something similar
where paramount
has been developing and developing
spending so much money and ramping their
slate up
to be able to launch paramount tv that
they just needed somebody to come and
buy something
like please would you come and let us do
this and amazon and paramount have had a
an interesting relationship over the
pandemic where movies like
um without remorse michael b jordan
starring tom clancy adaptation will
premiere on amazon instead of
theatrically
coming to america 2 was supposed to be a
paramount theatrical release it's going
to be on
like in a week we get trailers amazing
yeah it's like march 5th or something
like that
um i don't know yet what will happen
with top gun maverick but it would not
surprise me if that's also something
that happens in the back end
they've announced that i think part of
that paramount plus announced no that
was mission impossible
mission impossible was like four weeks
after theatrical it goes to paramount
plus
yeah which is bananas um but yeah so
we're going to get a live action gia joe
show centered around
lady j which uh which is interesting
um which seems as if maybe they get
their own black widow tv show
in a way that uh that's the character
that gi joe's built around lady j
lady jay i um
you know i i'll i'll watch but it's not
something that i'm like i can't [ __ ]
wait but like in the hands of anybody
anything could be wonderful and uh gi
joe i'm familiar with but
that was i didn't collect those toys and
i did watch the cartoon but like
it's not a part of my creative dna but
then again
neither was masters of the universe like
i did not collect he-man toys i watched
the show
yet we wound up [ __ ] making an
incredible
massive universe series uh bear mccreary
just texted me this morning give me a
link to tomorrow
he's uh recording the score for episode
four and five
so i've already heard the score to your
episode episode three
jeff's kiss just it's not
jeff is such a [ __ ] jeff just keeps
kissing
he just likes to kiss he don't he don't
touch or feel or ain't he's just a
kisser
he's the bandit jeff um
what else we got uh this one i think
will hit a little close to home is that
um ron moore is taking on the magic
kingdom universe
for disney plus ron moore is developing
a franchise
for disney plus that's set in beloved
magic kingdom um the first project in
the works is uh
of the so-called magic kingdom universe
is the society of explorers and
adventurers which is set in a world
where all the theme lands
and characters of the disney parks and
classic films actually exist in another
reality
huh
sounds familiar i was not following
along at home
two years ago three years ago kids i was
working on a show for disney plus
uh called kingdom keepers which was uh
favreau i don't know if he did the same
material but
uh essentially the story is disney after
dark what happens to the park
after you know [ __ ] uh the lights go
down and the gates are locked and
everything comes to life and [ __ ] like
that
so he was working on a movie and then
went away and i think he i forget which
he i think he went to um jungle book
instead
um so when disney plus was being managed
by
the disney channel um i was hired by
those cats
and wrote the first episode and the
outline for this
show kingdom keepers which was supposed
to be one of the first shows that they
were going to put into production
alongside high school musical this
musical
or whatever it's called and uh then a
guy
named um ricky got promoted
over the lady who was my boss and he was
a marketing guy from disney
and he's responsible for all the [ __ ] we
love like
he he was the one that was like we're
doing [ __ ] star wars and we're doing
[ __ ] marvel and stuff like that so
word was i never met the guy or talked
to him but this is the word that came
back to me for all the people i was
working with
uh he read kingdom keepers and was like
what the [ __ ] is this like all of this
ip
is in one show no no we're not putting
all these characters into one show
and [ __ ] got killed and now from what i
understand there was an internal battle
because
disney channel folks were in charge of
disney plus originally and then all of a
sudden
this put a kibosh on everything and and
uh it was
it was it was not a a uh happy
transition for some
uh me you know i was like i i never
believed it was ever gonna happen
um you know whole time i was just like i
can't believe i [ __ ] got this job i
can't believe
like you know i was like this ain't
gonna go and then i started to believe
it could happen because we
toured disneyland after dark they took
me onto space mountain we went through
walt's apartment we went everywhere in
the park after dark
with everything shut down on space
mountain we walked the track
and they turned all the lights on like
it was [ __ ] astounding and stuff so
then they also had me come over to
disney
to meet with the production team about
this new
system they had um which essentially was
is the wall the what do they call it the
[ __ ] the volume
the volume so um they were like this is
how you could do
you know your sets and backgrounds
without actually having to do them
because
a lot of your [ __ ] takes place in an
unreal world and stuff
because in the pretense of the project i
was working on is based on a
series of kids books called kingdom
keepers first one was called disney
after dark
um in in the pretense of the show we
were doing
you know once the parks close [ __ ]
the gates close
like everything is is alive so peter pan
is real [ __ ] dumbo's real all that
[ __ ] and whatnot captain hook he was our
big bad
um and uh you know it was
i often think about like during the
quarantine i'm like this would have been
the perfect time to shoot
it because [ __ ] disneyland is closed
cause that was the big question but then
when we met with the disneyland parks
people
the guy in charge of the parks was like
we can we could you could shoot a movie
here and we could still be open i was
like how's that possible he's like we
did it with uh
the mary poppins movie was it saving mr
banks or whatever
he's like there's two tunnels to enter
the park we'll just give you one side of
the opening gates and
we'll let normal people you know
customers come through the other side of
the gate
so we start and then i met a producer in
vancouver
like we went far and
i didn't believe it was ever gonna
happen until
i sat down with the producer until i
walked the track at space mountain then
i was just like
this might actually [ __ ] be and i
almost put off
jane salam bob reboot like i remember
jordan was like should we put this to
the side and i was like
you know that's ours you know whereas
kingdom keepers
is theirs and we could always be fired
from their thing
we cannot be fired for our from our
thing let's keep
that going just in case and thank
[ __ ] god we did because eventually
they pulled the plug
and if i had put off and like didn't
develop jane salam bob at all we weren't
pursuing it didn't look for money
we would have been [ __ ] you know at
ground zero and stuff so
at least this way something was still
going on and then kingdom keepers just
died and went away so i've always heard
over the last like three years like
hey they're trying to bring it back and
then that guy ricky left so somebody was
like hey it might be time again
apparently it is time but it's time with
ron moore
hollywood i mean you can't argue with
with
class and quality battlestar galactica
an amazing [ __ ] show i don't watch
the moon show and stuff but i've seen
some outlander like he's he's an ace and
so the idea is he's not doing kingdom
keepers he's doing
movies set within the disney
magic kingdom universe but creating
it's all very unclear you know and i'm
sure that they're keeping it very close
to the to the vest but according to the
thr
story um the idea for sources is to
explore characters like the seaboard
capture for the jungle cruise or the
prospector from big thunder mountain or
the climbers of the man of one for
example
as part of the world of the society of
explorers and adventurers which are
worlds that
within the fabric of the show actually
exist
um and to be clear none of these
characters or storylines are currently
on the table at this stage
um but yeah like it seems that it's
it's very much that thing which is
here's all of our characters in ip and
also treating the landscape as
characters in ip
and wrestling it all to the ground in
one show that seems to make sense
um for itself um
so yeah i don't mean
look i'm all for it and more
entertainment i think that you know
disney ip
uh in the disney world the magic kingdom
ip is something that you know they've
touched on like obviously with
pirates of the caribbean you can take
this [ __ ]
turn it into ongoing [ __ ] you know
beyond rides beyond little concepts
because
disneyland disney world is full of
storytelling like you know the
what is it called the explorers thing
you just said yeah society of explorers
and adventurers
what's on the walls all over the park
for wherever they you know if you're
going on the matterhorn or something
like that
so you know you could you you've got all
this [ __ ] that people have been seeing
subconsciously or consciously throughout
their lives while going to these parks
you know it's one thing to be like hey
pirates of the caribbean now that's a
[ __ ] movie
it's another thing to be like hey like
you know those dudes that like go up in
the matterhorn as you're waiting in line
and [ __ ]
that's a show you know i'm all for that
i co-sign that that's good
yeah so who knows when that will happen
but
it's a it's a pretty big deal for disney
plus um
to finally you know have a have another
take
on material that they've had plenty of
takes on before um
by the sounds of it thanks yeah very
happy for
mr ron moore uh no you know what he's
better off doing that kind of thing give
me [ __ ] like cartoons i can handle that
um but yeah that's and also again not
even the same thing he's doing something
sounds
um well i'm not gonna say cooler it just
sounds different
right um the matterhorn played a big
part in
in our show as well is the uh abominable
snowman or the yeti from the
he was one of our big bads he was a he
was uh the muscle for captain hook
and the other muscle was um the one of
the
moon guys from um space mountain
like in the one i think in disney world
is where it's upside down and there are
two dudes on the top of the ship
one of those dudes was also like the
captain hook
henchmen um it was it was pretty dope
man but uh
you know it was i got paid they didn't
make it but i still got paid and
i guess and i got to work with cool
people and stuff
um very cool people like that was
actually the project where i
i learned that um not like it was a
different business than the one i'd
entered because when i entered the
business back in the early 90s
uh you when you dealt with studio notes
they were [ __ ] terrible
and stupid and bad and like these people
didn't understand story
like but now the studio execs they hire
the creative execs
are creative like they they set me up
with a bunch of people
who were also [ __ ] writers so you got
people who are
like collaborators more than people
being like well you shouldn't do that do
this do this
um and i walked away from that
experience like very happy
because i was like oh [ __ ] like i had a
good time doing this like not just like
never had a bad note and [ __ ] like story
only got better
through the people that i was you know
working with and stuff
so you know good things came from it
like you know that came
right after the heart attack too where i
was kind of down for the count for a
little bit so i could just stay home and
write
and that paid bills and stuff like that
so no complaints whatsoever but
you know came close pretty close
i do think that it's it's always
instructive for people to realize that
more things in in hollywood do not get
made than actually do get made
um apa is a perfect example one point i
asked jj i was like man like
everything you pitch gets picked up and
he's like i'm glad it looks that way
i was like it's not basically going you
know how much pitching i have to do
in order to make the shows that i do do
he's like you don't see
the 90 of the pitches that don't go
anywhere
he's going you just see the ten percent
that make it [ __ ] so yeah
that he taught me a lesson that day
which was like
you know you don't pitch once you pitch
a lot and you pitch everywhere and you
pitch many different projects it's not
like one thing that you take from place
to place
you know that's why he's always stirring
a bunch of [ __ ] pots
so in the last year over the quarantine
i've gone in you know it's much easier
you don't go in you zoom
[ __ ] but i've pitched more in the last
two years
than i've ever pitched in my life and
you know it's
actually starting to show results like
good results like there's an hbo max
script that i'm writing with eric
carrasco that came from pitching
there's another hbo max project that
like
i think i'm going a second pitch on
which is kind of exciting and stuff
um and then uh you know then
we started pitching like these other
shows as well that aren't like genre or
from anything more
my kind of thing um but that's the key
you can't just like
take one stab you gotta you swinging and
throwing throw all that [ __ ]
spaghetti with or without sauce at the
wall that's what's
good yeah man um what else we got um
dc before we go anyplace yes
we've been waiting to do this jc has an
effect
to bring him in jc can you nightcrawler
into our shot with us please
come on oh my webcam broke though
but still we saw it you can see me on
there but you can't see me talk
no yeah oh you went away you're like i
got the harkness that was amazing he
snapped and he disappeared
come on back see if it'll work
oh my webcam hold on let me i'll i'll
try to set up the other webcam
you're a frozen avatar it's like come up
but then you just sit there
oh that's beautiful uh what do we got
while we're waiting for him to bam then
uh dc is uh is is moving forward
with their blue beetle movie that
they're making um charm city kings
director
angel manuel soto is set to direct blue
beetle
um the first superhero movie starring a
latino character yeah this
ain't the ted cord version it's the
jamie version right
yeah this is henry reyes um which was
created by
uh john rogers and keith giffin um
and kelly hamner back in 2006.
um so yeah i mean [ __ ] dc is is going
for it which is really impressive like
they're finally
they're they're realizing as i think
marvel was forced to realize that they
have
so many characters under the under their
[ __ ] giant tent
that it makes no sense to simply focus
on we're gonna make a lot of batman
superman and wonder woman movies
like let's just [ __ ] open the open
the coffers and see what else is in
there
and to be fair like you know ted court
is the best blue beetle we think of and
stuff because of the giffin to matthias
run on
justice league and whatnot but this uh
blue beetle
is a blue be the blue beetle for a very
an entire generation
that came up because he's been in the
cartoons as well yeah
so they're you know it's it's it's a
kind of a similar
remember when they did the green lantern
movie and they were like hey it's al
jordan
neil adams was on fat man on batman and
and he was talking about like why would
you do that why wouldn't you do jon
stewart because
an entire generation grew up with the
green lantern
as jon stewart because of justice league
but this feels kind of similar where
they're like look
let's do this [ __ ] blue beetle like
you know [ __ ] he's been around long
enough and against kids know him he's
been in the cartoon
plus it lends itself to of more of a
like a sci-fi fantasy version of the
character ted cord you know was a guy in
a suit
with a lot of money right um jaime's
character
isn't it like a [ __ ] magical scarab
or an ancient scarab that gives him
totally yeah like he discovers a scarab
on his way
from school and that night it becomes
alive and grafted itself to the base of
of taimi's spine and provided him with a
suit of extraterrestrial armor
which can be modified to enhance his
speed and strength and create weapons
and wings and shields and [ __ ] like it's
it sounds like it's way more attuned to
this generation
than ted kord was ghost um mkc
and chat said blue beetle is dc's
version of venom and i'm all for it
is that the idea it's like a symbiotic
kind of suit that
blends with him yeah i don't remember i
mean it's been forever since i read the
books i don't remember how
active the scarab is in terms of like
conversation and personality and that
sort of thing
but it's very you know sort of
bio-organic
um kind of polymorphing metal and [ __ ]
like that which is
super [ __ ] cool you know i don't know
how much it's going to make him
you know hang out in fish tanks and eat
raw lobster and stuff but
to each their own um some people are
asking in chat what our shirts say mine
is
uh asylum bob shirt that says
silence since the 90s a bob of few words
mark i believe is wearing mark's shirt i
am i'm wrecking my own merch
i'm taking the kevin smith lessons where
did they buy that fine shirt mark
that fine shirt can be purchased at
embattledclothing.com
emba tt led clothing.com
and if you use the code mark 15 you say
15 off your first order
mark 15 mark 15. that's kind of that's
your [ __ ] there's your series to go
pitch mark 15.
it's about a writer who writes things
better than the things that are written
15 better
um you go to what is it in battle
embattled what
embattledclothing.com for mark's shirt
you go the chive
uh the chivalry for mine they they make
a lot of cool j and zombop shoots
um jc what the [ __ ] man where's all the
bamfin
nightcrawler what's going on uh my i
think my webcam overheated i just put my
hand
on it and it's like a thousand degrees
that's what happens when you get the
smoke you came for this smoke and it
burned you up
so i'm i'm working on i'm working on
trying to get another one online here
um man i got one more news story and so
we got to do q a so you've got
you know four minutes you got a second
uh go ahead mark what we got last
uh last one is nickelodeon is launching
avatar studios which is designed to
create original content spawning out of
the avatar the last airbender animated
series and movies
um based in that world um we have
discussed in numerous occasions
um my love for avatar and your kind of
mild awareness
of it um which which i think is is is
appropriate but
um the original creators of the show uh
michael dimartino and brian
kinetsko are running the studio as chief
as
co-chief creative officers and their
first project is an animated theatrical
film that is set to
start production this year um which will
have nothing to do with netflix's
avatar the last airbender which is being
run by completely different people after
what sounded like a bitter split and
that's a live action version
that's a live-action version of it where
the two guys michael and uh
michael and brian had been a part of had
run into some creative conflicts and
eventually bowed away from
um you know and and so they are now
doing their own thing
there's going to be more avatar in the
world which i choose to believe
is a good thing um so wait
there they've got a deal at nickelodeon
where they're going to create
any animation or animation related is it
like a
avatar verse a cora verse or something
like that i think it's
i think at the very least they're going
to do more out of that universe out of
the avatar slash corey universe
i don't think it prevents them from
making brand new things
out of avatar studios from those two
guys um
but i think their first their first
mandate is we want more of this
um we want more cartoons we want more
you know movies we want more
from your brains in this world to the
point where they built a whole studio to
do it
i'm all for it um dr squee says no
mention of star trek prodigy first look
did you see this
um i did not see it i mean i saw the the
still images
they'd had out i guess when they first
announced the name
which i think was like star trek day
last year um but i did not get to see
the new stuff
from the the tca announcement this year
um they uh i saw a drawing that's bad
oh my god uh somebody just pointed out
cat image says it's 420 kevin i know
literally in california it's 4 20 and i
can't celebrate it um
the uh the uh
uh god was i just thinking i pitched
to nickelodeon uh this week and it went
very well
yeah were they were they uh welcoming
folks
very and you know i mean ironically
like i i don't know if i don't want to
pooch my deal or tell tales out of
school but
the person who i pitched to was a person
that i worked with on kingdom keepers
oh ricky no yeah
hey man remember me remember this space
um no but it was it was pretty good and
i also
i don't know how much to say because i
don't want to ruin [ __ ] but
but i should bring this up just by
virtue of the fact that a lot of people
have been saying
and chat and on twitter they're like you
guys got to have dave desmolchen on the
show again it's been
forever since you've had dave um i
i i i was i was
me and dave pitched something excellent
and it was it's his and it's brilliant
it's absolutely brilliant you know i'm
just kind of uh what do they call that
carpet is it carpet bagging are you just
hitching your wagon to the star
it was actually it came about like in
this really wonderful way where
you know the person that i'd worked with
at disney who's over at nick
like reached out to me a couple months
ago and says like i'm looking for this
and i think you're the guy and i was
like i'll start thinking i'll try to
come up with ideas
and then completely separately like
months later
dave hit me up and was like hey i got
this thing do you think this could be
a cartoon he's going you're working on
masters universe could this be a cartoon
somewhere
and i read the thing and i was like dave
this is this is
magical like this ain't this this
cartoon
this could be live action and i said and
it sounds like something that somebody
was looking for so let me see if i can
put us
all together and so so far
so good we'll we'll see um but it's but
his idea is stellar i don't want to
share it yet but
i'll tell you off air but it's jeff's
kiss
the moment i heard it i was like oh my
god it's one of those things where
you're like
why didn't i think of that but i'm glad
that he did he's so clever and stuff so
him and his friend reese
uh came up with this really cool idea
and we walked it into
nickelodeon so we'll see what happens
that's awesome dave is one of the nicest
people i know
he's so smart such a good dad such a
good husband like a real good guy but
boy oh boy does he like love this world
like he's a
genre guy in a big bed oh yeah yeah i
was very excited for him that he's
hosting we talked about it like two
weeks ago that chainsaw awards for fango
i was like i just like to hear nice
things happening for dave desmulcher
um here i mean this is like i don't want
to tell tales out of school but i i've
found this is new information to me and
i've
this it's a high compliment for dave de
small chimp
you've seen dave like in everything for
the last
five years ever since like what the dark
knight first time he kind of popped up
um you know normally when you see
someone that much
it's because they got a representative
an agent say or a manager
pushing them out there into the world
working on their behalf
um dave has a lawyer
and i think that's it so that means
all those movies that you see dave in
is about somebody going i like that guy
and just casting them
there's nobody out there going you got
to put this guy in your [ __ ] thing
people just love him that much like he's
incredibly easy to work with
he's talented he's [ __ ] like
character as hell and stuff
so you know he becomes a favorite of all
these people that just
pluck him up around the way do you know
how
wonderful you have to be to not sell
yourself in this business
to have people just trying to buy at all
times
so i found that was something i learned
recently and i was like that's [ __ ]
incredible man like
yeah it's a it's a big boon for him it
says
huge things about his talent man i just
absolutely love that yeah
and his talent and also like even if
you're super talented
you know that is entirely based on word
of mouth
you know word of mouth and vision on
screen and like
that guy has really interesting look and
he's really talented and funny
i wonder if he's an [ __ ] to work with
and every director who's clearly worked
with him who's then gotten that call
has said oh no he's a dream like you'd
be an idiot not to do this
you know and it's it to your point in
100 speaks to the kind of person he is
that like all he's got is incoming calls
and they're all on giant [ __ ]
projects where people are thrilled to
work with him
some folks have been asking what's with
the [ __ ] lip gloss uh since i had my
mouth open for like five hours and they
were working on it and [ __ ] like
it's i got dry like cracked mouth so
i've been
moisturizing like a [ __ ] and
stuff it makes those that came a lot
easier
yeah tell me about it for those that
came in late i had oral surgery on
friday if i sound weird or
look weird or whatever well that's if i
if i sound weird it's probably because
i'm not high at all
but to be fair kids i never really get
high anymore anyway
like basically weed for me is like
coffee for most people where they're
like oh i gotta start my day okay i'm
ready to start my day in fact
caffeine probably far more addictive
than [ __ ] food um but
to me it's not like hey man i don't get
[ __ ] loopy i'm 50 years old i'm a
grown-up
so i don't get high but i do get
centered
[Music]
semantics um do we is that the end of
our news
that's the end of our news brother two
hours after the beginning of our show
ladies and gentlemen this has been a
long one we're definitely
vision and the news what's that doing we
started like 2 15 and it's almost 4 30.
i know and when does the golden globes
begin because we got to get off because
everyone will start abandoning us
it uh begins at five o'clock so half an
hour we're cute and funny but we're no
[ __ ] you know
tina and amy no is that their name is it
tina fey amy poehler amy yes amy hit my
ear wrong for some reason
yes amy poland i would never say her
name her first name
alone so it was like i was missing
something and it was alaska
um are you gonna wash the globes i
really don't have an interest and i'm
not [ __ ] on it like you know being
the internet i'm just
i i think i'm gonna watch [ __ ]
captain america the first avenger with
my wife which has me really hot
there you go um i will probably watch
the beginning like
ultimately the only thing i'm ever
interested in at this point
is the monologue like i want to see tina
and amy do some funny [ __ ]
especially now on different coasts and
see how that works
because you know tina is in new york and
amy's in l.a or vice versa
is that what they're doing they're on
two different coasts they're on two
different coasts um
and so yeah i want to see what that
looks like because that's kind of
interesting
but i i have so few ponies in this race
like
i'll tune in to see if ted lasso wins
something i'll tune in to see if the
boys picks anything up or mandalorian
but
most of the movies i i'm sort of out of
that horse race on
um so yeah i could just as easily
watch the recaps or read the winners
lists tomorrow
then give it three hours tonight
um yeah i forgot man [ __ ] like mando's
up for things
and [ __ ] boys like there's a bunch of
[ __ ] we like
yeah and it's not to say like they're
always doing [ __ ] i don't like but
like genre [ __ ] which is kind of [ __ ]
cool yeah
so like i'm mildly interested and we'll
see how long my attention
span lasts uh get schwifty in chat says
kevin's high off life
no i'm not i'm not
i am acutely aware that i have stitches
between every one of my teeth and my
[ __ ] gums
um and life is just so
abrasive
so many sharp edges oh my god like i you
know you don't understand mark i live in
a nerf world most days
this is like i've come back to like a
world with sharp edges
it's like going from a from a nerf world
to like
uh like zack snyder's steppenwolf
the new version jaggedy very sharp and
stuff like that
why is everything pointy um did you see
they put out i watched some sort of i
don't know if it's trailer or what but
there's like this like uh it looks like
a minute and change maybe two minutes
i don't know what it's meant to be but
it's from zack snyder's justice league
and it has a leonard cohen song but it's
not
hallelujah and it shows the cube
like it shows cyborg
on the mother box and then does each one
of the characters
it like to me it looked like a credit
sequence but
i i don't know but it's it's acting as a
trailer i watched it on youtube
um clearly they're giving us that show
in the 133
ratio because it's imax is it going to
be black and white though
i don't think so this trip was all black
and white
i don't think so but i know that there's
a version of it that is all black and
white and i think that's zach's
preferred version of it
um and so maybe they'll there'll be a
way on hbo max to you know to do the
you know chrome and fury version that is
all just
black and white and and sharp and and
and pointy
and then the regular color version
where you will be able to actually tell
the tonal difference that like oh
superman's wearing a black suit
um instead of red white and blue a red
yellow and blue
black and white that doesn't go so well
when was the vanity fair article this
week or last week
um i think it was like monday of this
week mark kipped me to the
the vanity fair piece that they wrote on
the snyder cutter a friend of ours
anthony bresnikken
uh who mark probably knows from ew back
in the day as do well
um but uh um
really nice piece that really did track
the entire history of it worth a deep
dive reed if you're
remotely into the the snyder cut of it
all for sure
um but the one thing that they kept
talking about in that story which um
like i was like oh my god they're
absolutely right like they talk to
people and they're like he is
like zach is a legit nice guy and that
is
patently true like he is actually one of
the nicest individuals
i've met in this business and for a guy
who makes movies that are
high octane and [ __ ] like energy and
action
he's an incredibly sweet man i was so
glad to see that
come through in the vanity fair like
there's a reason the snyder cut [ __ ] is
happening and yes it has everything to
do with everyone online being like give
us a snyder cut
but it's also because like like
good things happen to good people guy's
a good guy
you know like whether you like his
vision of [ __ ] the dc universe or not
he's a good dude um so i'm happy that
he's he's getting this i'm not happy the
universe turned around to him but i'm
i'm looking forward to seeing this but
have you [ __ ] seen any of his
the the the [ __ ] dead movie stuff oh
the army of the dead
looks [ __ ] astounding ever the whole
world's talking about snyder cup and i'm
like
zombies in vegas with a heist
he's he's coming is a big year for him
and those two projects are like kind of
back to [ __ ] back he owns streaming
right now
yeah and he's also got like they've
spent we talked about it before they're
spinning an animated series
out of the army of the dead movie that's
following each one of those characters i
think
um yeah no zach there's something that
seems to be
for him energizing in a weird way about
being out of this
part of his part of his life you know
that like as much as he loves these
characters as much as he loved working
with those actors
that there's something about getting on
to do the other work that he wants to do
that seems really um exciting to him
which makes it exciting for me because
you know i i may have had my issues with
you know man of steel
and bvs and justice league but i always
thought he was an incredibly talented
guy
you know and there are lots of movies of
his that i do like quite a bit
um so to see more from him his dawn of
the dad is [ __ ] flawless
i mean before i came here it's a tall
order because i loved the original dawn
of the dead and still
somehow they made a [ __ ] dawn of the
dead where i'm like put it on the shelf
right next to the other one it's real
great
yeah um somebody asked uh
uh let's see or no obi-wan yarobi says
zack is releasing two versions
one in color one black and white this
has been confirmed on ign so you'll be
able to watch
both you can watch the snyder cut
or the clerk's cut which is entirely
black and white
um uh nicholas quaglia brings this up i
don't know if we
if i mean it's a rumor so we might as
well hit it because it's definitely in
our world but
all last night on twitter uh amber heard
was trending
because the there there's a rumor it's
not been in any of the trades
nor has it been substantiated by warner
brothers um
but there's a rumor that she's been let
go of from
aquaman 2. have you heard that or see
that online i haven't all i did see was
the trending part of it
um but i didn't see any of the the
attendant
scuttlebutt seems like a lot of wishful
thinking on people's behalf
more than fact like um because this
happened once before too couple months
ago they were like
she's out and then it there was no truth
to it it seems to be somewhat fueled by
sort of fantastic beasts fans
who were somehow being forced to choose
between johnny depp and amber heard
and so potentially spinning you know
false truths about um you know her
relative value in hollywood
and her career prospects going forward i
don't know if there's any truth to it at
all
um but yes before i think that was part
of it
um buick space wagon says not confirmed
by any of the serious
sites so we don't could not be it could
possibly
be not true at all yeah um tj
asks did you see the new image of the
joker for justice league
um in that vanity fair piece there was a
picture of uh the joker
wearing a crown of thorns um which
uh i was shocked that like you know if
you did that [ __ ] 20 years ago somebody
would be like
you know there'd be an outcry but
if it didn't seem to have any blowback
whatsoever
reminded me of i remember when i first
got into comics like the second time i
was in the comics as a kid but
when i met walter flanagan and started
hanging out with him
um walt is an artist so i got to plug my
computer walt is an artist and so
you know i was just brand new into
reading all this [ __ ] and [ __ ] like
he got me back in
through the killing joke and dark knight
returns and batman the cult was out and
stuff
so i remember being like hey man like i
need you to draw
a [ __ ] image of batman crucified
on a cross and the joker holding the
nails in his teeth and a hammer and [ __ ]
and what was like i could do that and he
drew it and [ __ ]
oh that picture that's what it reminded
me of i was like oh my god
[ __ ] in one tiny small way
i and zach are similar
religious iconography with our dc
characters indeed it's a passion play
yes yes turning it into a passion play
of sorts
uh is that all the news we got that's
all the news brother
it's all the news kids uh give it up for
mark bernard and he gave you the [ __ ]
news
um jay and songbob secret stash kids
opened on monday of last week the new
place
open for business and stuff um so you
can go see that if you're anywhere in
the
new jersey new york area only they can
only let 10 people in the store and at a
time but
place is big enough um but
there may be a grand opening coming soon
yes we'll be we might be releasing some
details this week
for a grand opening where it might be
jay and salam bob might actually be
there
so fingers crossed don't forget too
uh movies pop-up is coming to orlando
it's almost completely sold out thank
you everyone in [ __ ] florida
who's who came out in droves you know
we've got i think it's something like
3 200 slots and i think we only have
3 000 or 200 left so we've already
booked
yeah it's these movies movies pop-ups
are fun
and they're well organized in as much as
you get a reservation so
we know who's coming at all times we
could keep people socially distanced and
stuff
but like most restaurants you know you
open up in the morning like i wonder
who's coming in
this like we use the talk reservation
system
by the time we hit the ground and open
you know at a place in this instance
we're opening at the tin roof
in uh orlando which is downtown orlando
near the big orlando
eye ferris wheel and [ __ ] we know
like in advance how what has to be
prepared who's coming when and [ __ ] like
that
but i just want to take this moment to
shout out the folks that have uh
pre-ordered and stuff because derek who
runs our movies operation derek berry
uh he's a genius derek said that um
for the second time this happened in
phoenix it's also happening in orlando
and all the orders so far the pre-orders
because you know it's like
i don't know what it is like 37 bucks to
get you in the door and that gives you a
meal and blah blah blah
for all the pre-orders people have been
tipping
[ __ ] huge so in all the pre-orders
they already know they've got
like fifteen thousand dollars in tips
for their workers
that's huge like it's one thing to like
come and
patronize the place at all that's good
for the restaurant of course but like
the fact that my people are [ __ ]
tipping
like big like that means a lot so thank
you that not only does it make me look
good
is a really kind thing to do everyone's
struggling out there and stuff so
thank you in advance of that but i will
be heading to orlando for the opening of
movies on march 12th
and that puts me on the east coast so
maybe i head up to the motherland
um all right jc can you banff back
yes look at that [ __ ]
honey look at the budget we have on this
show
i've got the old webcam so i look like a
vampire but uh yeah it's it's on it's
working
i can disappear are you are you leery
about bamfing in and out
is that what's doing it no i i didn't
have the air conditioner on it was like
90 degrees in my studio i think i
literally think the webcam overheated
um how are things in your world how's
the kid uh she's good
she's discovered she has feet so that's
the big uh
that's the big exciting thing this week
she's not sure that they belong to her
yet
but she's just she's decided that there
are feet around so that's
uh has been fun can you imagine there's
a time in our lives where [ __ ] just
looking at our feet was
that was one division
like oh look at this [ __ ] like chaos
magic
oh yes how nice every day is a [ __ ]
discovery for you
that's why babies don't smoke weed
they're constantly on an adventure
well like she's she's gonna be four
months old and she's never left
the house she's been to the doctors
three times but she's never
left our house can you imagine
that's crazy that's a covet story right
there yeah wow
yeah or that's like a buffalo new york
story if your kid is born
in the winter um all right do we got
questions uh we do uh the first one from
matthew lawton
uh if you had to pick a
dc or marvel villain to babysit your kid
who would you pick and who what hero
would you pick
as a godparent all right so i'm picking
a marvel or dc marvel or dc
the villain is the babysitter the hero
is the godparent
god parent is definitely bruce wayne
because you getting good gifts lots of
probably cash gifts so hands down is
bruce wayne
um what villain do i want babysitting my
kid
what a weird wonderful question i know
i'm trying to wrap my head around it
i mean bullseye could be interesting for
the kid because you'd be like see this
paper clip watch me kill your cat with
me um you know
let me see well first off we don't want
any anybody's gonna put kids in jeopardy
yeah the joker seems like a bad pull
harley's not bad though harley quinn
might not be a bad
baby in terms of you know she's kind of
an anti-hero
um
gorilla grodd
kid would kid would take the kid back to
ape city
kid would see a whole bunch of cool [ __ ]
that most people don't get to see
talking [ __ ] apes and [ __ ] like that
solomon um
and remember remember that the gorilla
that took care of the kid when he fell
in the cage
harambee he might
he might take care of my kid there you
go grilla grodd let me see is there a
marvel villain
definitely not loki no
no certainly not agatha harkness
although we know in comics like she was
the you know they
the fantastic four sue and reed gave her
franklin richards
to to watch and raise and you know she
took that kid on an adventure
um
magneto might not be a bad
gotta babysit your kid
you know there's not too much terror
there especially if you live in an all
plastic house
[Laughter]
what about you uh i also was gonna go
magneto
um i think lex luthor might be a pretty
decent babysitter
um because he doesn't seem to have
antipathy towards children
you know at least children who aren't
from outer space like i think he likes
humans just fine
you know and uh and he would he if you
told him you have to watch this kid i'm
sure he would outfit
whatever house he was going to be
watching that kid with the best [ __ ]
technology
to make sure that kid is happy and and
well distracted
that kids get a lex or suit [ __ ] yeah
that kid's gonna have the best time
um as far as a hero to be the god parent
i kind of feel like steve rogers is
impenetrable in that particular arena
like captain america is the dude who's
going to take over for you in case you
or your wife pass away
i could trust you rogers for that i buy
that
um that's a good question yeah well done
uh matthew lawton well done matthew who
would you do jc
doc ock is the babysitter hands for
everything he could clean the house
while he was watching the kid
and uh uh plastic man as the god parent
that's good run out of fun things to do
and he could be considered a villain too
because el o'brien used to be a bad guy
before he became
plastic man and stuff so i like that
that's classic man's good call
he's always getting left out man
[ __ ] you know he's he's
he's not mr fantastic but he can do the
same [ __ ]
uh okay question number two this is from
mark pippen thompson from facebook
because we are getting slack that we
never take facebook questions so this is
uh mark
thompson from facebook uh with marvel
pulling out characters that
make us furiously youtube and wikipedia
who they are
which lesser known dc peeps would you
guys like to be serialized
hold on i just want to point out louis
sanchez says y'all bugging sons tripping
out magneto babysat the new mutants and
doug ramsey died
[Music]
fair you know what respect respect for
that kind of memory
all right one more time sorry jc um
mark thompson uh which lesser known dc
peeps would you guys like to be
serialized somebody like the
agatha harkness or these kind of marvel
deep dives who would be
good dc deep dive phantom stranger
alan moore wrote a wonderful i mean
every alamo
whenever he handled that character
handled it wonderfully but he wrote a
secret origin story for that character i
think he was the author of it
that uh takes it back it takes you know
because phantom stranger
there there was no real origin or
anything like that
he gave him an origin that he was the
soldier that slapped
christ or something like that or helped
crucify
jesus and hence he was cursed to walk
the earth for all time and stuff
so you're talking about an endless being
who's been around for all time
you could totally do fun things with
that character i mean ago the hardness
has been around for what 400 years or
whatever this guy goes way the [ __ ] back
to to uh you know the start of the a.d
calendar
so yeah phantom stranger i mean of
course i'm always
hyped for question the question to have
his own series and whatnot but he seems
like a major character whereas
phantom strangers still kind of you know
undiscovered gem of the dc universe and
you could totally [ __ ] do a whole
series about that guy particularly
because you can go all over
the time span
nice um similarly
i think vandal savage would also be kind
of fun
um vandal savage who you know at least
according to dc lore
was like a chrome magnum you know he's
been around for whatever 10
000 years this immortal dude who's just
seen it all and done it all
and uh and over that time has just
learned everything
and is now this like crazy high level
you know not even time traveling which
eventually he would get to be able to do
but is also immortal um and i think
there's there's some highlander fun you
could have with an immortal character in
the dc universe
love it all right come on back jc
trey 2100 in chat said
something i agreed with which i don't go
that deep on dc
but um i loved the gray ghost episode of
batman the animated series
and thought he would he would be great
in a in an episode
i think he was created just for the
animated series
like i don't think comes from like deep
deep dive
yeah no if i remember correctly i think
that was created for the animated series
okay last question billy reynolds uh
with one division which is in mind
which shakespeare play would they
convert to a
superhero story so if marvel were to
lift the plot from a shakespeare play
what shakespeare play would make a good
marvel movie
i mean romeo and juliet you know could
translate very easily if you've got
a good guy and a bad guy who fall in
love or something like that
um um
you know macbeth is probably witches
yeah it's got witches in it so that's
pretty easy to translate over
um what an interesting question i mean
hamlet
you could kind of do a you know my
father the king has been killed by my
mother
and [ __ ] her his brother and
and you know um
i i know and i've been visited by my
father's
ghost and that feels like that i mean
that sounds like a [ __ ] marvel story
right there
what about you um i mean the one that
came to mind
and i will admittedly say that i do not
know as much about it as i should
but as the tempest um which i think is
legit about magic um you know about some
a shipwreck on an island and that island
is the home of the sorcerer who's got a
kid i want to say maybe i don't remember
um but i think it's about power
you know yeah wasn't it his name caliban
yeah
you know and prospero maybe was also
from that
yeah because eros books yeah
um you know similar like a midsummer
night's dream
is also about [ __ ] you know fairies
and
love and loss and you know pucks and all
that [ __ ]
um i mean all of the tragedies
are there for you but you know finding
ones that automatically lead themselves
to magic
um you know to that point othello
could also be um you know a trusted a
trusted general or a trusted wheeler of
magic is betrayed by everyone around him
um for not having that same level of
power
is also kind of fun um but yeah wow that
is a deep interesting question relying
entirely upon
knowledge of shakespeare which i could
not have guaranteed that we would have
there are some really nice suggestions
in uh
the chat john chadwick says black
panther already had shades of hamlet and
macbeth
very very true um a lot of people say
uh do mid uh dick mcwillie our fave
midsummer night's dream using the
multiverse great [ __ ] call
um what's this about the inhumans
oh it went past real quick somebody
pointed out the inhumans
um pratimash
uh rang hundenhan says caliban is
prospero's
slave i think i i really don't remember
the story of the tempest
uh the shipway says it's got to be
othello there's barely any superhero
films without a love interest
old school shinobi says howard the duck
and dr bong
in cory alainis
[Laughter]
david bonner points out forbidden planet
was based on the tempest
oh well there you go yeah i forgot that
that's true
um well [ __ ] that was that was a
i didn't realize we'd end on such a
smart question what if you did something
uh with the x-men with like gambit and
rogue and it was taming of the shrew
hmm the only way you get away with doing
taming the shrew these days is if the
shrew is the guy if you flipped it
you gotta flip it otherwise people are
like you misogynistic piece of [ __ ]
so you gotta the shrew's gotta be the
dude that some lady's gotta tame
um you know it should be jack black
should be the shrew
yes i would watch that kate winslet can
be the
the tamer yeah jack black as wolverine
and kate winslet as as jean grey
matt bowler saying taming of the shrew
starring wolverine
i just said it dude
um well [ __ ] kids that's
that's the show right there it is indeed
way too much show but uh you guys seem
to enjoy it and i seem to enjoy i enjoy
the [ __ ] out of myself
mark you have a good time i always have
a good time my friend
uh jc bam finn here and tell us if you
had a good time
yeah i look forward to it every week um
anything we will keep doing it kids
we're gonna keep doing it
of course this is what we do this is our
show
and how fun it is to you know you gotta
appreciate
this is something like me and this cat
we're
creators for a living right like the
idea is we gotta make some [ __ ] up all
the time
doing this [ __ ] ain't writing doing this
[ __ ] is fanning out
and what got me to be a writer in the
first place is being a fan
so when we do this show it takes me back
to the
organic origins of how i got to where i
am in life
so it's important you know to
self-express
um and tell your story but it's also
important to love [ __ ] that's how you
get here in the first place you can't
be it unless you can see it and growing
up i saw all sorts of stuff
read all sorts of stuff that led me to a
world which still gives me happiness i
had i'm gonna say it again
i had horrible oral [ __ ] surgery on
friday
but you know i came home and i watched
[ __ ] age of ultron with my
lady and stuff and made me feel made me
feel better
so this [ __ ] i love fanning out about
this [ __ ]
sitting around and [ __ ] gushing about
some other
person's art you know it's
there's something there's something
really pure about it
you know like me and him could easily be
sitting here
[ __ ] on everything you know
strategically
so that we can raise ourselves up but
every week when we sit down and
kind of love on this [ __ ] it's you know
that's us taking off our professional
hats and putting on the
hats that [ __ ] we wore in childhood
that led us to this place in the first
place
so thank you for affording us this
opportunity to do because if nobody was
watching i doubt we'd keep going
but the fact that you guys not only
watch but then also chime in and [ __ ]
have great questions and
it's a it's a i love this it's one of my
favorite parts of the week
cannot wait till we get to go back to
the cantina and do it in person
you know hopefully by like thanksgiving
you could easily right because you're
all sorts of [ __ ] you got the
vaccines right i got my two times
you see you got both i got both yeah man
i've been looking
on you know online like keep refreshing
[ __ ] one site that's like has all the
california locations and [ __ ] but
still ain't eligible hopefully soon
hopefully soon
fingers crossed my friend um super
looking for that super soldier serum man
give me some of them vita rays make me
all
[ __ ] chris big and [ __ ] hell yeah
they like black panther have i [ __ ] up
two times i just got a text message
saying l.a county teachers
restaurant staff and grocery store
clerks can get the vaccine
can sign up for covet 1919 vaccine so
you may want to
rewind 20 years go back to the quick
stop you might
might qualify i could tell them when i
sign up they're
like what do you do i'm like i'm known
for clerks
just leave it there you still got your
old id
yes that's true a quick stop gave me a
[ __ ] clerk id that i
still have yet to throw out um boy that
doesn't help me at all jc so [ __ ]
thanks
uh ladies and gentlemen that's all we
got for you man you have a good time if
you had a good time
this cat down there over there mr mark
bernard and he brought you the news and
[ __ ] like that
uh we don't get to do this without jc
who's our
mr mojo puts it all together puts us
online
and then bamfs in and out of our lives
look at that [ __ ] look at that
production value that was sexy
yeah you don't see that [ __ ] on
entertainment tonight is that still on
do they still making a game tonight i
think they do
well you'll never see jc banffin in and
out or anybody bamfing in and out
uh come back next week kids on saturday
i promise you
you're gonna want to be here we got a
real cool guest
that's that's the well we'll tell you
about it next week but uh
definitely worth being here for never
mind uh you know conjecturing about [ __ ]
we're gonna get
details facts yeah from some inside
[ __ ]
personnel and [ __ ] the nitty gritty and
the gritty
yes both of them but not the gritty in
texas we don't want that nobody wants
that gritty anymore
one of their grids was named gritty
that's the gritty one is the one that's
like keep hearing those news reports
we're
like i got a 17 thousand dollar electric
bill that's that gritty [ __ ]
i'll take the nitty and we'll leave the
gritty way out
um yes but come back next week ladies
and gentlemen uh
right after wanda vision uh on friday
saturday we'll be doing this probably
four o'clock that sound good gentlemen
sounds right right
we'll be back to our saturday at four
o'clock slot uh with a very special
guest
and uh it'll probably be an all one
division episode to be honest with you
um
but uh it'll be fun we'll make it fun
there it is kids
mark where can they buy your shirt one
more time embattledclothing.com
one last time
those titties on the glass i'm like show
them your shirts like put them on the
glass
put them on the glass uh if you want
this [ __ ] you go to the chivalry.com
they got jane salam box shirts and stuff
janesonbob.com also has some stuff but
not these shirts uh
and jane sonibob secret stash is open
ladies and gentlemen and uh look for a
grand opening
announcement fairly soon oh my lord
there it is kids i'm not smoking weed
why am i coughing what the [ __ ]
i normally say not covered just weed but
if it's not weed
ooh i better not have covered i'll tell
you that don't even
um there it is kids uh for fat man
beyond
i'm kevin smith i am mark bernard tune
in next week
saturday 4 p.m same fat time same
fat channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith chaos magic [ __ ]
you